okay good morning everybody I know that
they're
excuse me still some folks uh who will
be coming in to the room uh
representative Davis and uh
Howard
um but I want to get started uh we're
already past nine o'clock
um I would request representative
Creighton please to uh lead us in the
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
I'm going to open up this morning's
hearings
with SB 162.
and I believe there's someone here from
representative pearls uh sorry Senator
Pearl's office to
Old Habits time
to introduce this bill to us good
morning and please state your name thank
you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Peter O'Neill I'm
the legislative aide for former
representative Pearl currently Senator
Pearl uh he's actually chairing energy
this morning so I will be introducing
this bill on his behalf Senate Bill 162
is relative to exemptions from rabies
vaccinations for dogs cats and ferrets
this bill makes the initial period for
an exemption from the rabies vaccination
for dogs cats and animals annual with
the recertification of a veterinarian
the other two pieces that Senator Pearl
wished for me to introduce to the
committee was that he had worked with
the Department of Agriculture to get
this language set for this bill I
believe there are a couple people who
want to speak on this as well behind me
and this bill was also brought on behalf
of a constituent unfortunately I won't
be able to take any questions and that
will conclude my introduction
thank you very much I appreciate it
does everyone have a copy of SB 162
in their possession okay thank you
so thank you madam chair we can proceed
then of our next speaker on this bill is
uh commissioner Sean Jasper from the
Department of Agriculture good morning
commissioner
foreign
is for one year and then thereafter it's
every three
and then in this case we're talking
about an exemption so there is actually
no rabies vaccination this is just
certifying on a yearly basis that there
is a an issue that would not be in the
animal's best interest to to have that
vaccination I appreciate that thank you
representative smart good morning
hi guys good morning everybody thank you
madam chair
um
what
I guess I I don't understand what would
be the harm in the animals what is
harming The Animals by having a rabies
vaccination
um that is something that I think the
gentleman who is going to speak after
after me could could speak to I'm not
really familiar with the health issue
um
you know the real difference here is
that instead of going to two
veterinarians every time every year this
would just be one so it's really having
the initial certification and then
than just saying all right you only need
to go to one instead of two can I ask
them yes but just to clarify your
question because I've been on uh we've
heard rabies bills in the past and uh as
I understand there are some uh pet
owners who say that they're pets after
they get a rabies vaccination get
extremely sick
they have reactions just as humans may
have some reactions to certain
vaccinations as well
so in order for them to protect their
animals from having these kinds of
reactions
which some of them are life-threatening
they ask for exemptions from the rabies
vaccination requirement so all animal so
not everybody's Exempted only if they
have a reaction exactly
yeah okay
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I guess I I also have a brief
question with lines I guess nine and a
half through
12.
what happens in the event that there
isn't a local animal control officer who
would be the presiding authority over
that
uh
uh local well the police are always the
local animal control office they may not
have somebody designated all they
believe they do but that is a police
function to be
um Animal Control
so in the event that there's not a
specific follow-up Madam chair yes sure
thank you madam chair so in the event
that there isn't a specific named local
rabies
Control Authority you would that would
bother the police yes and I you know in
In fairness this whole issue we know
that there are a lot more unvaccinated
animals out there who should be
vaccinated but who are not uh than there
ever would be animals that would be
exempt under this
so there is that issue you know not
unfortunately not every pet owner is
responsible in not only every pet owner
gets a rabies vaccination for their
animal as required
thank you
any other questions from the committee
for the commissioner
seeing none thank you very much uh
commissioner Jasper as I told you I
would be a very poor substitute for Dr
Crawford I'm sorry uh representative
Bixby
um
having heard this presented in the
Senate I think one thing that came out
there and if you you can confirm this is
that one of the reasons for
having the re being reduced from needing
three signatures initially to one
signature thereafter is that the three
signatures become a bit of a paperwork
work burden for the Department is that
correct uh I would imagine it would
would be we I don't believe we have many
exemptions but I would say that that is
another issue when uh and after the
initial exemption really does not seem
to serve a real purpose
thank you commissioner
I would like to call now Chuck Douglas
to the
microphone good morning
there we go
as the speaker
did not say
um this actually is and I know you've
heard it uh actually a basically a
housekeeping Bill to clean up
the requirement that representative
Bixby noted which is that if you want to
have your dog cat exempt from rabies
because they had in the case of my dog
an anaphylactic shock the dog almost
died at Russell Animal Hospital here in
Concord
they were able to save her little four
pound Yorkie but
it led me to look into this whole
question of rabies and the exemption
the law already has the exemption so
we're not asking you to expand or
subtract from what the law is
but every single year
to get our dog
registered annually in our town
we have to get the vet at Russell to
reaffirm that she would get an
anaphylactic shock and die
then we've got the fun part of finding a
diplomat
uh in the veterinary field that's like a
board-certified surgeon
try to find one of those in the North
country
try to find a vet anywhere you've got a
long waiting period then you've got to
find one who is a diplomat
and then Dr Crawford the State Vet has
to sign off
so all this would do
is save a lot of paperwork
because after the first
time the dog or cat has been certified
to be exempt
thereafter
it would just need their vet to annually
recertify so we're not trying to avoid
a vat looking at the situation for your
pet
but
um
it's very onerous and I don't know how
people out in the rural areas do it I
mean we're in Concord area it's you can
find a diplomat he comes to caves once a
week so we have to schedule our magic
day when he's going to be there
he doesn't know anything about the dog
but he figures well if Russell Animal
Hospital says it's okay it's good with
me
then we have to go to Sean's office and
have Dr Crawford sign off and to do that
every year I predict there are a lot of
citizens who aren't doing it at all
because they can't they can't find a
diplomat they don't know about the law
or they don't care we care but we would
like to make this process a little bit
simpler and that's really all it does
there's no hidden agenda no secret
ball being hidden from you where in
August they'll read you know thousands
die from unvaccinated dogs or anything
like that
in fact the law still says as is our
case
we can't allow our dog Outdoors unless
she's on a leash
and frankly we don't let her outdoor
anyway because she's kind of Eagle meat
but
um we
we also have to have the dog on a leash
that doesn't change
so you're not going to have pit bulls
running around unvaccinated terrorizing
neighborhoods
it's very rare but there are animals
that just like humans my wife is
allergic to penicillin
I've got a kid that's allergic to latex
and that's the same thing in the animal
world so it's really that simple
it would be in the interest of everyone
who has gone through the process of
getting their dogged or cat
properly exempt to just not have to
fight to find this second vet every year
as well as Dr Crawford so it's a it's a
way to simplify the process
be glad to take any questions Madam
chair thank you very much a question
representative germano thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
questions and and I think you've
answered at least part of my question
and something you just said so and
looking at lines nine through eleven and
then 12 and 13 uh there would seem to be
kind of two scenarios here right nine
through eleven referred to an Exempted
animal Shelby remain uh maintained in
strict rabies isolation under conditions
that are at the discretion Etc until sex
time is the medical condition has been
resolved right so if there's a temporary
I imagine if an animal has an illness
right and a vaccination at that time is
delayed or right and then at that point
your local veterinarian could determine
that it is safe to uh to have the
vaccination or uh another scenario is
the case that you just as I said
answered I think in terms of if it's
just because the animal uh would die as
a result of the shot in that case you
just have to maintain those isolation
procedures
rare I think the more common is if they
are exempt because they've had
a bad bad reaction
they the dog once they recover or the
cat may be fine
but because they're unvaccinated you
can't let them out
unless they're under your control
so you either have to be a house pet
which our little Yorkie is I mean she
doesn't even like to go outside she
doesn't know what green grass is she's
happy inside but like cats some cats
don't even like going outside so fine so
they're exempt but every year we still
have to have the vet sign off on it
because there are maybe situations where
they recover or their immune system
changes and they're able to be
vaccinated
um but that's I I think the norm is just
that they're more like house pets
thank you sir thank you madam chair
thank you any other questions from the
committee
uh representative coulon
oh yeah thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm just
wondering if you know by any chance how
you guys qualified the animals on the
bill that says dogs cats and ferrets I'm
just wondering why
um other animals were left out of the
party like a guinea pig or a goat or
chinchilla or something like that well
section one
uh which you don't see in the bill
because it's unchanged in the law and
section one's been around a long time
and it says every dog cat and ferret
three months of age and older
I do not know
why it was limited to that
decades ago but that's the way it reads
so if you have a cow or a horse that's a
totally different
situation this is more
the town Clerks
annually you know collect uh I don't
know 25 bucks or something to register
your pet
um
I know when we lived in Beau our town
clerk every year knew we were going to
be late because we had to get all these
magic signatures
and medulla Nayak said I wish the
legislature would simplify this because
the clerks have to babysit people who
need these exemptions
why chinchillas or other animals I I
couldn't tell you we're only
I think the reality is dogs and cats are
going to be the overwhelming yeah number
of pets that are involved here yeah
thank you that's what I understand yeah
representative Bixby yeah I think
another aspect of that is that in terms
of uh roots of transmission uh
dogs and cats and ferrets are more
likely to bite I mean yes sheep can get
rabies but they're not you're unlikely
to be bitten by a rabid sheep whereas
the likelihood with with dogs cast and
ferrets is higher
yeah
any other questions
thank you sir thank you we appreciate
you coming to testify today would uh
representative Davis can you please pass
up the blue sheet
I online we had uh two folks Pro and one
their supporter opposition online and
we had uh two folks Pro that one Mr
Douglas and Senator Pearl
okay and I will close out the hearing
for SB 162 and open up the hearing for
sb211 is relative to background
investigations of solid waste and
Hazardous Waste Facility permit
applicants
and I have
um Senator Pearl speaking for five
minutes however we know he is not
present good morning again I'm back
again thank you again Madam chair and
members of the committee once again for
the record my name is Peter O'Neill on
behalf of Senator Pearl I am his
legislative aide and we'll be
introducing Senate bill 211. this bill
adds to the requirements for background
investigations and criminal records
checks for solid waste and hazardous
waste facilities for permit applicants
and this is relative as that of joe red
to background investigations of solid
waste and Hazardous Waste Facility
permit applicants Senator Pearl wanted
me to mention to the committee that Des
wanted the bill so Senator Pearl had
this filed and there were some redrafts
with language but eventually we settled
on the amended version that came out of
the Senate and that Des agreed to this
language as well as the stakeholders who
had some influence with this bill once
again unfortunately I won't be able to
take any questions and thank you very
much for the committee's time thank you
okay any other he he won't be taking
questions so I will then now uh ask
director wimsat from nhdes to come up
and speak
um in support of this bill
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Mike Wimsatt my service director of
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services Waste Management
Division and I appreciate the
opportunity to come before you today to
testify on Senate bill 211. so uh as uh
the gentleman from Senator Pearl's
office indicated this is a this bill is
a request of New Hampshire Des
um and we and we fully support the bill
uh so for many years New Hampshire law
has required that applicants for both
solid waste and hazardous waste permits
for facilities
basically submit to a background
performance history check at the time of
their application and and the reason for
that is really to ensure that an
applicant who is seeking to run a solid
or a hazardous waste facility has the
reliability expertise Integrity
competence to operate a facility and as
part of that in addition to Performance
history there is a requirement to do a
background check of criminal records
background check of the key officers and
employees of the of the of the proposed
facility and one of the reasons for that
is that we are directed that uh we may
deny a permit to someone who is Seeking
a a house space or solid waste facility
permit if they have been convicted of a
felony in the previous five years prior
to the application so the only way to
know that for sure
is to conduct a multi-state background
criminal investigation a records check
for those parties and so that has been
done for a number of years but in just
recently the New Hampshire Department of
Justice uh informed us that the language
and the statues which has been there for
decades in both the Hazardous race and
the solid waste statute isn't properly
constructed to facilitate use of the
federal criminal background system so
the FBI basically the way that these
background investigations are conducted
and and I would know they're conducted
in for many occupations uh people who
work in the schools uh bus drivers that
sort of thing are all submitted to this
kind of a records check and it's pretty
commonly done pretty frequent it's done
through the New Hampshire State Police
but as part of that and of course they
can do everything in state but for a
multi-state across the country
background investigation they go through
an FBI database the Federal Bureau of
Investigations and the FBI is very
particular that if you're going to use
that system the enabling language and
the statutes that enables you to do it
needs to be constructed in a very
particular way and doj is informed us
that our current statutes aren't
constructed that way so we're seeking to
fix this and without this fix we will
not be able any longer to conduct uh
background criminal background
multi-state criminal background
investigations so this language would
accomplish that we work very closely
with doj to make sure we had the right
wording and we uh certainly uh support
this and hope that you will find it uh
approvable uh and with that I'll leave
it and be happy to answer any questions
thank you very much any questions from
representative
thank you madam chair and thank you
director for taking my question just out
of curiosity
um
have there been any issues with anyone
applying for these permits that we have
found uh
a problem with in the past my and this
this precedes my time as director but my
understanding is there was one facility
a solid waste facility where one of the
key officers had indeed been convicted
of a felony in the previous five years
and they were informed that that would
not that that permit would not issue
with that person in in in in leadership
in the company and as a result that
permit did not issue
any other questions from the committee
so director wimsat this is let me just
restate and say that so this change to
statute just brings our language into
line with what's required with
um FBI background checks that's correct
that's interesting so it's really more
it's a it's housekeeping but
um in a manner which complies with
federal law
that's fair statement okay thank you
seeing no other questions
um
I'd like the anyone else wish to speak
um I'd like to Blue sheet for this
please
and there has been no comments online
thank you
thank you and we have uh Senator Pearl
uh registered Pro support for this bill
on the blue sheet with that I'm going to
close out the hearing for sb211
and we are just a minute shy of our 9 30
for SB 23 and I want to bring to the
attention of the committee
um
I received back from our house Clerk
a senate message
for a bill that we had HB 152 having to
do with soil and plant additives
um
and that bill came back with an
amendment from the Senate which we are
asked whether we are going to concur or
non-concur with this change
um
I believe I discussed this with uh
Senator Bixby and and I'm sorry
represent I'm getting ahead of myself
here representative Bixby I'm getting my
senators and representatives all mixed
up today
um but uh apparently they they changed
some wording in here uh regarding the
purchase of uh fertilizer
um the the statement is penalty payments
received from the registrant she'll be
refunded to the consumer of the
fertilizer which has been analyzed and
found efficient provided that the
purchase is of one half ton or more as
I would love you to speak to that
um and I believe that the committee
should concur with this change but go
ahead so um when I brought this uh
before the the senate committee
um Senator Pearl noted that he had the
experience in term uh with uh as a
fertilizer dealer and noted that a
deficiency in uh of of less than half a
ton would uh could add up to a matter of
a sense or maybe a few dollars and that
uh the paperwork burdened to the
department for uh dealing with a number
of a very large number of very small
fines uh could uh outweigh the benefit
that uh would be received that would be
gained by that so
um
uh he he said that he would be fine
dropping it from a full-time which is
what current law has to a half ton but
uh dropping it down to you know for any
amount would uh could create a paperwork
burden that outweighed the benefit and I
said that I was fine with that uh would
that change so I think that we should
concur with this
um
and uh so that that's my my feeling on
it okay just by a show of hands are we
all okay with concurring with this
change
okay thank you very much committee I
will now open up um SB 23 which is
establishing a study committee on meat
processing
and
um
who I have for this speaking I I guess
is uh Senator Innis
Dan Ennis from Bradford New Hampshire
representing District Seven good morning
Madam chair members of the committee for
giving me my allergies are acting up I'm
mildly medicated so speak slowly uh but
I think we'll be all right
um it's the unfairness of spring in New
Hampshire
um but it's all good
um this bill is being brought forward
um to you uh Senate bill 23.
um
okay
in part
um well in whole
um because I've learned a lot in the
last couple of years about farming in
our state and getting things from Farm
to Table and some of the difficulties
that exist in doing so for small farmers
and this bill simply establishes a study
committee to start to take a look at
this particular issue and consider how
we might perhaps be able to make things
a little bit easier for small farmers
around our state and this one focuses on
what we call non-amenable species so
this isn't typical cattle or chickens
but rather would be bison deer elk and
that sort of thing and we do have some
bison farmers in our state there's one
in Warner that I'm very familiar with
there's an elk farmer in Lee New
Hampshire and some others around the
place
and this sets up a study commission that
that consists of members of the the
Senate and the house
and we'll begin to dive into this issue
commissioner Jasper is here to speak to
to it as well and provide a little more
insight but the the objective here is to
consider how we might be able well to
understand the current situation but
then to consider how we might be able to
make things a little bit easier for
those small farmers there is one thing
about the bill that I think maybe we
need to adjust and that's in line 31 of
the amendment actually
and we have a completion date of
November 1st 2023 that may be too
aggressive as I think about it and maybe
June 30th of 24 would be a a wiser way
to go with that
um
so I'm happy to take any questions and I
know the commissioner can answer
questions in probably greater detail
than I
thank you
thank you Senator Innis any questions
for Senator Ennis
so
um
there's a
uh you may be aware that there's a
certain reluctance on the part of house
leadership to take on a lot of study
committees yes and one of the issues is
that the burden typically falls on the
house to field most of the members of
the committee how would you feel about
sharing the weight equally and having
two senators and two reps on the
committee rather than one and three
thank you for that question and I would
be delighted actually I know of a
senator who'd be perfect for this okay
so yes thank you thank you
okay then
all right that's an amendment then uh
that we would be happy to uh
I appreciate that representative um and
along with that Amendment so you are
also suggesting that the um the report
that's produced should have a due date
of June 30th 2024. yes please I think
that's reasonable and it gives us enough
time to adequately study this okay okay
all right
representative Creighton
thank you madam chair Senator
ideally what would you envision that
committees report
recommendations I mean if you
what what would this commit at the end
of the day ideally what would they
produce
they will produce recommendations on
ways to streamline the process for small
farmers to ensure that public health is
protected right that's important
um but in many cases
um
it's it's a little too difficult to get
things done and and you'll hear from the
commissioner in his testimony
how it works and and why it can be a
little bit difficult but you know
um I think focusing on the non amenable
species to start is a good way to move
into this and in the ideal World in a
year or two
um we start looking at other options
I'll give you a and you know the
commissioner can speak to this too if
you produce meat birds for example to
sell it can be difficult
um to get those to Market unless you use
a USDA facility and there are some
issues in getting time at those
facilities sometimes that are distance
away and quite frankly what's important
to many of the small farmers in New
Hampshire be included is that animals be
treated humanely and you know if you can
avoid major processing plants where
there's more likely to be disease and
find another way I think that makes
sense and it will help our small farms
to be more productive I could sell a
chicken to you from my farm store but I
can't sell it to a retailer same bird
unless it goes through that USDA
facility so that's the objective here
let's help our Farmers while we're
protecting the public health make it
easier to get to Market in the longer
term it will take time to do this and
maybe I'll run into a wall and that's
okay you know but I think it it's
something we need to explore for our
farmers in our small communities around
the state it's a tough It's A Hard
Scrabble business in New Hampshire no no
we've got a lot of them in our districts
yeah I understand yeah I grew up in Ohio
where you put a disc in the soil and
plant a seed it grows not so much here
so we have to be a little more creative
and I think anything we can do to smooth
the process is helpful thank you great
thank you representative Murray
Madam chair for taking my question
um so one of the questions that I didn't
have was
thank you one of the things that I was
just about is the scope of the studying
committee and and looking at you
mentioned obviously public health
component and then you mentioned things
like the USDA access to USDA or avenues
that way but are you also looking at
educational components to like getting
new folks into that
that's not specifically in the amendment
or the bill
um but I don't see anything wrong with
representative coulon
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
um I was just curious if maybe a study
commission like this could lead to some
sort of um you know voluntary labeling
system like New Hampshire grown or
something easier to identify food yeah
you know produce in New Hampshire by
small farmers I think it certainly could
yes awesome well we just had breakfast
with the New Hampshire uh young Farmers
Coalition so good I'm glad to know there
are a few young Farmers out there yeah
I'm I'm I'm I'm new to the business but
it's it's a lot of fun and I think it's
it's it would be great for our state to
continue to maintain our small farms
absolutely thank you the part of our
culture honestly
any other questions representative dutzy
uh yes thank you thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question so just
to clarify and I apologize for my
ignorance but so if uh so right now if I
shoot a deer I can have it butchered for
my consumption is that correct that's my
understanding yes but if I want to sell
it then we have to go through the
existing process USDA and we know that
that's all backed up is that pretty much
where we're at I'll let the commissioner
give you the details on that I think
he's better able to speak to the details
of deer than I yeah thank you yeah
raising deer on a farm not not I know
some folks do it but I think less common
any other questions from the committee
thank you Senator Ennis thank you
appreciate it good to see you
I call now uh uh commissioner Sean
Jasper from the Department of
Agriculture
Madam chairman members of the
commissioner members of the committee I
am still the commissioner
tongue tied
um so I am in favor of Senate bill 23. I
I will say though in terms of the
creation of the state Meat Inspection uh
program which we have on the books that
is still something we support
eliminating because it just has no
potential to survive without extensive
uh State funding I don't see that
happening and that would not be my top
priority for the Department anyhow
however I think there is a lot of value
at looking at the non-emanable
processing question
um and I really believe that that is
about traceability and clear labeling
for the consumers
I think if people choose to buy those
non-eemenable uh products in there know
that they're not USDA inspected and and
that they know where the product comes
from that is something they should have
have the right to do
um and that's really because that is not
under Federal jurisdiction the feds have
left that out so say well why not extend
that to all other species because we
can't
so you know that's the simple answer but
it in answer to your question yes if you
wish to sell deer meat
um to the public it would have to go
I'm glad to answer any questions
representative Howard
thank you madam chair thank you for um
answering the question
um this this weekend I met with some
Farmers from Massachusetts who um we
were talking about Slaughter and they
were they said that the USDA um
uh slaughterhouses down there were sort
of too expensive for the smaller farms
and that there was they still have state
inspection in Massachusetts from what
from what they told me
um for and so the smaller farmers were
bringing
were had sort of egregious terms set by
the state to to do smaller loads
um
and I have to say that I'm I'm puzzled
by that I haven't received any evidence
of that because the federal laws require
the exact same standards
at a minimum for a state program as
exists for USDA inspection so I'm not
sure how that that would work because
you would still have to have a state
inspector there of course you know
everybody else talks about oh well Maine
does this Massachusetts does this
Vermont does that they have his sales
and income tax
and so they throw a lot of money at a
lot of things that we don't have money
to throw at but the standards are the
same
um
what we have done here through the use
of Opera funds and next Wednesday we
should be finally awarding the uh the
grants we did have
uh 750 000 going out to various
processors in the state to expand or
modify their facilities there's a lot of
good things going on in the processing
we expect it to become more available to
the farm
uh to the small farmers not only that
working with Cooperative Extension will
be standing up a
mobile class partially online partially
on site so that people who are
interested in learning those skills will
have the opportunity to do that which
should also help with the availability
but there is this false narrative at
least from what I've seen that oh yeah
we need a state inspection program
because it won't be as as rigid won't be
as expensive I just simply don't know
how that that is possible and the only
thing I can say is that if you had a
state program and you had a few small
processes perhaps they send their
inspectors here one day here one day and
those processors might only be open a
day or two a week and that's a shared
resource but the way our program is is
set up would be more expensive because
uh the people having the animals
slaughtered at a state program would
have to pay
for the full costs of that inspection
whereas well I shouldn't say a full full
cost I'd have to pay for half cost feds
would still pay for half
but as it is now they're not paying for
the federal part of the inspection so
um that's not a path unless the
legislature said hey we've we've got a
million million and a half dollars we
don't know what to do with let's put it
into a state Meat Inspection program
I don't think that day will ever come it
hasn't arrived and I started hanging
around here in 1984 and haven't seen
thank you representative Bixby yeah
could you just
um go over what the current
um procedure is for dealing with not
MediCal animals so yeah for for an elk
Farmer for deer Farmer for a bison
farmer what do they do now in order to
be able to sell their meat other than
from a Farm Stand
well even from a Farm Stand if they are
not
um
going
through
the USDA inspection
and some some facilities will deal with
those but some don't want to deal with
with a bison
the difficulty of those un Untamed
animals going through that process some
won't deal with it
so there has been nobody who has legally
done any of that at this point because
you have to have a veterinarian on site
to inspect the animal
pre-mortem and post-mortem there has to
be lab testing there has to be you know
a lot of things that are supposed to
happen I don't have them memorized
because they've never happened and
nobody's ever requested we did
find out that there were sales
um
of Bison uh I don't know if it was bison
doesn't matter abnormenable species out
there that had not gone through the
process and that's when it was looking
looked to be expanded to Elk like during
the last legislative session said see
there's been no problem with the program
we have now when we looked at it and
said well gee there's been no problem
with it because nobody's actually done
it correctly
so
um
there is no no shortcut and even those
who have large herds have said it just
simply too expensive to do it the way
so uh so the the Farms that are doing
elk and deer are having those animals
processed at USDA facilities they would
they would have to yes in order to
legally sell them and they are and uh
for uh they are
um
uh where was that going with this um so
do they have more difficulty getting
their animals to slaughter facilities
than uh someone who is doing a minimal
amenable animals
in terms of schedule that I I wouldn't
know I think that would depend on the
facility
um I you know I do know I went to a
small processor so let me be clear if I
wasn't you don't have to have the animal
fully processed at a USDA inspected
facility has to be slotted there so you
can have it slaughtered there
and then taken back to your
non-inspected facility you can still
then sell it from a store from anywhere
as long as it was slaughtered at a
facility I and
um I don't know the difficulty if
they're having any more difficulty or
not I would suspect probably for alka
bison probably not for Elk or deer
probably not for bison as I said
um those are very large and wild animals
and I think they would be having much
more difficulty getting somebody to deal
with that since their Slaughter dates
are generally full anyhow
representative Murray
um thank you madam chair for taking my
question
um thank you commissioner
um so one of the questions that I had
was whether or not the study committee
might take a look at those non-amenable
species that we know were being imported
for sale in New Hampshire from other
states and I Know It Grocers uh I have
seen some of these non-amentable species
on the shelf for sale but they're coming
from outside of New Hampshire so I'm
curious to know what impact that has uh
you're telling me something I I didn't
know about so I really can't
answer it I I would
suspect they still have to be inspected
for the USDA facility and I would hope
that there is traceability I mean where
that has become a huge issue with all
food products these days so uh certainly
something they could look at but I don't
any other questions from the committee
for the commissioner
seeing none thank you very much for your
um so it seems we've
heard for this particular Bill a
possible Amendment
to be added not only to change the date
of the report but also to change the
composition of the committee to be two
members of the house and two members of
the Senate
representative
thank you madam chair
um
and although I like the idea of two and
two I think we should leave it at three
reps and two senators just to make sure
we have a quorum
um anybody else have any thoughts on
that
uh it was three members of the house and
one member of the Senate yeah uh we
might want to make it three and two
give it given that and with a quorum of
three yeah and just just because
um those of us who have worked on study
committees in the past have noticed uh
an inconsistency on the part of the
members across the wall and made able to
so we're looking at three
representatives and two senators I think
if if you think the you might want to
consult also with the speaker to make
sure that that would be amenable to him
as it were uh but
um but uh that you know it might be
okay so that's that would be for
purposes of a quorum of three right okay
all right
let me uh I will work on an amendment
for that then but I will speak to the
house speaker for that
um and so far as hb20 SB 23 the blue
sheet we had one person sign in
favor
um
and no one online
so I'll pass it on to our Clerk
and I will close the hearing for SB 23
our next bill is coming up at 10 15 so
we'll take a short break
unless is there anything the committee
would like to discuss at this point
before
we take a short recess
I need to change that but it's it you'll
never get a senator to show up hardly
ever
false
um
excited
[Music]
you understand why I said three and two
thank you
um
animals
it is uh 10 15 and so we will open up
House Bill I'm sorry Senate Bill 159
and I invite the sponsor
Senator Fenton
to speak and introduce this bill to us
thank you thank you for having me
thank you madam chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton I
represent District 10.
uh Senate Bill 159's purpose is to study
the department environmental services
issuing any future unlimited service
area landfill permits and to study the
out-of-state waste coming into New
Hampshire
we are seeing New Hampshire Soul become
a Dumping Ground for trash from other
states
a report from the environmental
environment Department published in
November shows that more than 45 percent
of the trash coming to our landfill
comes from out of state sources
Massachusetts has not built a landfill
in 30 years because it seems like their
Solid Waste plan is to dump it in New
Hampshire
Maine pass legislation prohibiting the
disposal of out-of-state waste in the
state's landfill Vermont has also
established aggressive standards for
what can be disposed of in its landfills
at the rate we are going it might not be
long before we are seeing barges coming
into Portsmouth from South Carolina with
their trash
New Hampshire recently updated its Solid
Waste Management plan with its goals to
reduce in-state waste and trash toxicity
it's a great strategy like Recycling and
composting but it fails to address the
problem that almost half of our waste
comes from out of state trash
I urge the members of the committee to
consider this bill
um and if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer them questions from the
committee
representative Bixby
so
um one uh we currently have have a solid
waste working group and I'm wondering uh
why it would be better to do this as a
separate study committee rather than
having this uh be covered by the saw uh
the solid waste working group absolutely
thank you for the question I think if
it's in the solid uh waste working
groups uh bylaws or statutory laws I
think it's a it can be covered under
that the issue that was brought up with
this is that out-of-state trash is not
being addressed
and where in other states are
phasing out building landfills it looks
like there may be landfills in our
future
um I think Vermont has one landfill
whereas New Hampshire is debating on
potentially more and what we need to do
as a status figure out how do we stop uh
single waste pollution and also stop
trash coming from out of state that's
that's the Crux of the issue is the
trash is coming from out of state
uh representative Murray uh thank you
madam chair for the question thank you
senator for the question
um so
in the event that the
are you also seeking input from folks
who may be able to weigh in on
interstate commerce clause and uh those
types of things that might
come under the purview of this
discussion having served on a study
committee regarding this I just it's a
great question I think that's the
elephant in the room right the Commerce
Clause how do we get around that and I
would say that um you know
it's up uh studying that issue in and of
itself is a whole other thing but it is
a I I would welcome individuals who are
um
understand the interstate commerce
clause and deal with it daily uh to
testify or speak in front of that
committee I think
um it's not up for us to determine the
out-of-state Commerce closet signed up
for Des either to discernment what is uh
what does and does not pass that out of
representative germana
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question uh thinking about
what virtue a study committee might have
would one of the benefits of of a study
committee perhaps be that when a
report is is concluded in November that
you have a group of legislators who may
already be in a position to put forward
some legislation uh hopefully bipartisan
legislation House and Senate legislation
so is that potentially a benefit of
doing it as a study committee as opposed
to going to the working group
thanks for the question I think that is
um a great point you know the whole
purpose of this is uh how long can we
wait you know we're at 45 trash from out
of state is it going to go up to 50 is
it going to go up to 55 uh where does it
end and if we don't address it now
when's too late
thank you Senator thank you madam chair
Senator have you spoken to
representative evil
she is chair of the solid waste working
group have you spoken to her about this
we haven't spoke thank you for the
question Madam chair we have spoken um
there there is some overlap
um we haven't seen the address of
out-of-state trash
being necessarily addressed sorry that
was a double words there um but
as representative germana said it's
really to get something out by hopefully
next legislative session
okay because I'm also a member of solid
waste working group and I know there are
various issues and topics that
um that they are covering and I believe
that this is one that is going to be on
their list of things to look at
um so I I'm I'm just hesitant in
duplicating work thank you madam chair
absolutely absolutely I'd be hesitant to
duplicate work as well I think um if
that is the subject you're covering and
you are going to get to it I think then
uh you know it would uh you wouldn't
want to wait
representative Murray thank you madam
chair for taking my question
um senator
I think to get to the point of of your
specific piece of legislation you're
looking at unlimited service areas
versus areas where there are limited
service area landfills is that correct
so you would not be looking at that
other
correct group thank you for the question
correct so we're not looking at limited
service areas we're looking at unlimited
service areas which accept trash from
um
representative Bixby
um could could you explain a little bit
more about how the permitting works for
a limited area Service uh limited
service area
um
facility versus an unlimited service
area and what how did
um how does uh
how is he determined whether the permit
would be limited area or unlimited area
thank you for the question I will
describe it as best as I understand it
um a limited service area would be like
uh your county or specific to towns
things of that nature a certain
demographic area geographical area uh
whereas an unlimited service area the
way I understand there's really no
parameters except potentially what type
of trash you can take that's the way I
understand it so you can get trash from
Vermont Massachusetts Maine uh Iowa you
there is might be town or Municipal
level who receive only within that
jurisdiction correct thank you
the way I understand it representative
Bixby yeah so is the are the limits on
the service area determined by uh who
owns the landfill or is it and so for
instance with Nashua Nash the city of
Nashua owns the landfill so they can
choose their service area uh but
um
with uh say with uh TurnKey in in
Rochester that's owned by waste
management and
um I don't know that there's a matter of
the permit saying what the service area
is it's a matter of that of of turn of
Waste Management
um accepting uh trash from clients
wherever they find them so
representative I think I understand your
question
um yes it determines there's a lot of
determining factors of what area you
service and what trash you take in I
think it deals with uh municipalities
determining that and also the
application process in which they're
applying for Des as well to determine
what they're graded for I'm sure Des is
behind me chomping at the bit to correct
me on some of these so uh you'll get
another chance at this
thank you
representative Howard
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
um I don't know if this applies to the
interstate commerce laws but given that
some of these landfills are meant to be
profitable and the permitting of it
probably includes ways to be profitable
including taking trash from out of state
where
what would you like to see the committee
conclude regarding Commerce
thanks for the question in regard to
Commerce I think um you know I think we
all want a
cleaner New Hampshire
um and I think uh if you're not upset
that you know 45 of our trash comes from
out of state uh you know there's an
issue there um you know we're not trying
to hamper business by any means but
we're also not in the business of
becoming the trash state to accept other
to to connect with representative
Howard's question is also I believe and
correct me if I'm wrong uh a question
here in terms of our landfill capacity
and increased costs for New Hampshire
residents right I mean if you have a
landfill that's closer to you and it is
filling up with almost half of the trash
being uh brought in from out of state
and then the result is ultimately that
your own local trash then has to be
shipped further you're talking about
tipping fees going up and increased cost
to New Hampshire residents
to ship our garbage because we can't
handle it in a local landfill it's
taking a lot of out-of-state trash
if I understand yes there's a cost
representative thank you for the
question there's a cost to everything uh
in the long run it's going to cost the
residents of New Hampshire a lot more
money and uh maybe the quality of our
our state air trash like that we're also
seeing uh you know garbage trucks
literally just driving up from
Massachusetts uh there's no there's no
special transportation of this trash
it's literally just dump trucks getting
on our highways driving up to us and
dumping their trash you want to talk
about about an environment on top of
that uh you know those trucks don't get
great gas mileage so you know it's uh
cheaper for them to do that than it is
for them to figure out the problems
thank you thank you madam chair
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
would you say then that it is a
permitting question would you like to
see the permitting of our landfills be
more restrictive
thank you for the question I think uh
that's why we have a study committee I I
believe that
we can find a solution in here somewhere
um I think we're all in agreeance that
we want to do something here uh dealing
with out-of-state trash and if that is a
permitting process if it's a new
language in terms of how we approach
Solid Waste or out of state waste I
think there's a there's a ton of options
and I would hope that the study
committee can figure that out thank you
senator
representative Murray
sure um thank you senator for the
question
or not there's a concern about
um
at least Gathering or absorbing some
data about
materials that might come in that are
hazardous or contain other contaminants
um and is there a way to establish what
percentage of those are coming
from uh into those unlimited service
areas from out of state or if you're
intending to look at that I think that's
an excellent question and I I'm sure Des
is behind me and I would ask the
pertinent questions that uh what exactly
is coming from out of state what type of
any other questions from the committee
do we export any Trash any waste it's a
great question
um
I'll have to ask the es behind me
any other questions from the committee
and I see none thank you very much for
your thank you for introducing the bill
today and I wonder uh if director wimsat
might come
to the to the table I I have a couple of
questions regarding this that but you
know there were some figures and numbers
tossed around regarding
um percentages of uh out of state trash
and
I wonder if you if you know uh more
specifically what those percentages are
for how much how much out-of-state trash
comes to New Hampshire and how much do
we export out
thank you for the question
um you know so for the record Mike
wimsat I service director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Des
um
the numbers that the senator was putting
out there were about right I think it's
around 45 for the last year where we
have reliable data just a couple years
back it was on the order of about 45
percent uh came from out of state and uh
the amount of waste that New Hampshire
exports is less than 10 percent
um it varies from year to year but it's
on the order it's a single digits what
are the types of things that we export
you know that's a great question I think
they tend to be things that are just of
convenience if you look at the border
and you've got a business they may hire
a local trash hauler that happens to be
housed across the border and use a
facility you know in Vermont or in Maine
or something like that they're I'm not
aware of any sort of specific
um you know deficiency in New
Hampshire's ability to handle waste I
think it's more a function of
convenience
uh yeah representative germano thank you
thank you very much Madam chair and
director for taking my question it was
connected to the to uh the chair's
question about what we we export
um do do we do you know do we export
some uh food waste because I'm thinking
about like in Keen we've got a kind of a
startup composting business and he'll
compost for example like coffee cups
that are compostable right you need to
have a certain uh amount of compost
right I mean those are those are food
waste specific sites and I believe he
exports out of state so it's just a
question connected to the chairs
question if that's an example of
something that we tend to uh ship out of
state that's probably a great example I
know that a lot of supermarkets um that
generate a significant amount of food
waste already have arrangements with
out-of-state facilities to manage their
food waste so that's probably represents
a meaningful part of that percentage
thank you director thank you manager and
so I know that you are also a member of
the solid waste working group
um and I'm new to that uh body and I
wonder do you do you know of any plans
of solid waste working group addressing
this issue of out-of-state trash
so the solid waste working group is uh
you know has in its first year of
operation really focused pretty
significantly had a strong focus on the
development of our state Solid Waste
Management plan and now they're really
beginning to start to take individual
topics and and learn about them most
recently we've spent a couple of
meetings with presentations related to
food waste reduction actually
um so I do think that the the chair
wants to develop maybe you know look out
in the next six months and and decide
which topics the group will will uh
we'll review in detail um and that
certainly could be one of them I don't
honestly know if it's specifically been
identified as a near-term uh topic of uh
investigation thank you for that
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair
um director wimsat I'm interested in how
we actually Trace Trace what out of
state trash is coming you mentioned the
last data that we have how do we measure
it right so every every facility every
permanent facility is required to file
what's called an annual facility report
or an AFR and those are due in the
spring of each year and then we you know
spend some time compiling that
information
and that's why I say I think I think the
the year that I'm probably quoting is
one year back because those reports have
just become due and we haven't compiled
the data for for 22 yet but um basically
that those annual facility reports are
required to include a host of
information related to the types of
waste that have been accepted and the
origin of the waste so that's how that's
where we determine how much of the waste
that has been received at our disposal
facilities comes from out of state thank
you representative Bixby
thank you for taking my question
um
so I'm the the study committee is
talking about looking at unlimited
service areas and in terms of Permitting
and I'm wondering whether
uh there are separate types of permits
for limited versus unlimited service
areas and whether that is dependent on
the type of ownership of the facility
and and whether it might be whether
there's even a possibility of saying
well we'll do a limited service area
permit and they're sure and use that to
get rid of out of state waste so so
really the decision about what serve
what area a particular facility wants to
service is is that of the applicant that
when they decide they want to propose a
facility and they decide who they want
to service who they want their customers
to be they provide that information in
their application and for we do have a
number of limited service area
facilities in the state and I'll just go
through them because I think it's
helpful to understand city of Nashville
operates its own own landfill its
service area is limited to the city of
Nashua and um then there are a couple of
uh uh communities associated with
um their former Solid Waste District
that can also bring asbestos waste
specifically to but for MSW and straight
up trash
um basically the city of Nashville only
accepts waste from within the city
limits
um Lebanon landfill is the limited
service area landfill it's a little
broader than that it includes I think
about six or seven New Hampshire towns
and six or seven Vermont towns and
that's the service area that they
specified we didn't we didn't dictate
that as part of permanent that's what
they asked for and that's what they got
for a permit and then the Conway uh or
the uh
Mount Washington Valley facility takes I
think from Conway Albany and Eaton
that's the service area that they desire
to serve and that's the apartment they
have so to go to your question if um you
know I guess to put it in practice in a
permitting scenario let's say that a
private company came in to uh and
decided they wanted to have a limited
service permit to operate a Waste
Management Facility in Nashua
that would be a little bit of a tough
road to hoe for them because the city of
nashua's facility
serves Nashua and serves it adequately
so when we would look at doing a public
benefit determination for a facility
like that we would likely conclude and I
don't ever like to prejudge anything but
we'd likely conclude that a facility
that was only going to provide service
for Nashua wasn't really needed because
there was adequate service for all of
Nashville's waste so that you know is we
could that's an example of a very
hypothetical example of how a decision
might weigh in with respect to either
limited service area or unlimited
service area in practice the commercial
facilities that come to us those those
facilities I described you before are
all municipally owned and operated the
privately owned and operated facilities
that come before us for permits
typically request an unlimited service
area which means they can take waste
from from anywhere thank you
representative Creighton you had a
question yes ma'am chair thank you and
thank you for your testimony
um just trying to wrap a couple things
around my head here so you said that the
solid waste working group was looking
for additional topics to study
with respect I'm not sure I said it that
way we we have a directive under the law
that that outlines a number of topics
that we can and should study and what I
guess I what I should have said is the
chair is trying to decide in what order
we take those and and how we how we
study them I don't think that the chair
or the the group as a whole is looking
for new expanded things to study with
the the the job we have under the under
the law that created the solid waste
working group is already big enough so I
think we're trying to limit what we do
to those issues that were identified for
our investigation for a follow-up good
and is this and this is not one of those
um I I don't think the term unlimited
service area appears in the law that
created the solid waste working group
there certainly is discussion about
um I think there's some reference to
out-of-state ways but I I apologize I
don't remember exactly what the language
was
I get I mean in my mind rather than
committing you know resources to another
commission
it was saying to me you got the right
people in the right place to do this in
an amendment to this would say hey you
guys are already working on it work on
this too would that make sense to you
yeah I I don't want to testify for
anybody else so I'm speaking just solely
on behalf of the department I believe
that um we recognize that there's a
difference between something like the
solid waste working group which is a
group of it's a really
robust group of people from all across
different uh expertises and sectors we
have people from the solid waste
industry we have people from the
hospital Association we have a whole
host of folks who bring a really great
core of knowledge to those discussions
we recognize that a legislative study
committee is a different animal that
it's really just comprised of
legislators and it and it you know and I
think the chair you know has articulated
to me uh representative evil that you
know her uh study committee House Bill
413 which looked at really broadly at
solid waste a number of years ago it was
a really powerful tool that she really
appreciated being able to use because
being comprised only of a handful of
legislators she could schedule meetings
and she had something on the order of I
don't know 15 or 16 meetings in the
course of two months and they were able
to bring in people from all across the
sectors of information they were trying
to gather so I I wouldn't and again I
want to emphasize DS did not come today
prepared to take a position on this bill
we don't start a position on it and
General we generally we never object to
custody committees because we feel if
the legislature decides it wants to
study an issue it should who are we to
object or support it either way so I we
don't have a position on it but I but we
do recognize that there's a difference
between the kind of work a working group
like the solid waste working group can
do and the work that a legislative
committee can do
perfect thank you
option uh thank you director
um so to your
um
so to enter to I guess follow up on your
statement about there being roughly 45
percent of trash imported versus the 10
export
um would you in with regard to this
proposed piece of legislation feel
confident that the data that you have
from uh last year
um which would be 2021 correct I think
that's right yes
um would be sufficient in their findings
to be able to do the study committee I I
don't yes I don't have reason to believe
that the data once the new data we're
collecting once analyzed will be
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you so much for uh for
coming up at my bequest you're welcome
and I appreciate you taking some
questions even though you were not
expecting to speak on this bill today
and I would like to see the blue sheet
thank you representative Davis
there was nothing uh no no testimony
online or support or opposition
or
SB 159
we have two people
who have indicated Pro
this bill
with that I'm going to close the hearing
for 159 unless anyone else has any other
comment
thank you
and we will take a very short break
because in three minutes we will be
I will talk to her about that and I
okay
I'm not gonna I'm gonna be leaving in
I don't know what that would be but
um
yeah
why don't we do that because it's that
way
sure for this and I'm gonna go sit over
better
teacher
um sorry
testimony on 267. okay
okay I think another thing but it could
come out and solubles yeah yeah that's
it Gene pills up I'm gonna talk to
um
foreign
so we will be getting underway with uh
the hearing for Senate bill 267.
and I see Senator Al Schiller
so I will open this hearing for SB 267
requiring the commissioner of Department
of Environmental Services
to consider cumulative impacts analysis
in rules and statutes and I invite
Senator Al sheller who is the Prime
sponsor of this bill to come in
introduce it to us thank you
for coming this morning
good morning Madam chair good morning
committee members thank you very much
for your time this morning
written remarks that I'm giving you now
will be coming in there's a copy issue
happening so thank you very much my name
is Deborah alchler I represent Senate
District 24 which includes the towns of
Exeter Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton rye and stratum and I'm here
to introduce Senate Bill 267 which has a
new title relative to the rulemaking for
advanced recycling facilities
granted this bill has had a major change
since its introduction
and I would like to speak to the uh the
reason we we need to do this and we're
where We've Ended up and I put it in
your hands after that if we only knew
then what we know now
I wish I knew this would have been great
to know beforehand
all statements of regret those are all
statements uttered after a decision was
made without all of the information
needed to make a good decision
the repercussions from bad decisions
made out of ignorance
don't mitigate Damage Done
but hopefully they guide our future
decision making
we have an opportunity right now to
guide good decision making for the
future of New Hampshire's air water and
soil qualities because we have good
information that we can use to be
proactive in this venture
there is an emerging and untested
Industry in the country which is
referenced in the original bill
and we actually have a pilot program for
it here in New Hampshire and it's called
things are often named for that which
they are sort of but not really for
instance I live on Apple way and there's
no apple orchards anymore so you kind of
get that so Advanced recycling as an
industrial process it brings a broad
range of toxic pollutants through a
process of high heating for production
of what is referred to as feed stock to
be used for the production of new
Plastic Products
what is in the Plastics being repurposed
include per and polyfluorinated Alkali
substances pfas Benzene heavy metals and
polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons that
can be present in plastic materials
processed through advanced recycling the
potential for such toxic pollutants to
result in air water and soil pollution
that is harmful to the public health and
the environment
New Hampshire has the unfortunate
experience of dealing with widespread
pfas pollution that has resulted already
in public health emergencies closed
drinking water wells and has spurred the
federal government to help bring in
cleaning up the polluted areas and we're
still not done
what we didn't know when we were using
pfas Laden products and I say what we
didn't know
things like firefighting foam was
exposure to pfas the per and polyfloral
Alkali substances has been linked to a
range of health problems including liver
damage thyroid problems weakened immune
systems cancers developmental issues
reproductive problems in in the form of
decreased fertility and Cancers that
include liver testicular and kidney
Cancers and that is not even an
exhaustive list
we may not have known all of those
things until fairly recently but it
turns out that the maker of the most
commonly produced products with pfas in
them did in fact documents recovered
show that the DuPont company's own
researchers knew back in 1961 that this
chemical was toxic and then they
proceeded to bury that information while
producing thousands of products that
have done and still do real harm to our
public health and environmental safety
in 1978 3M knew through their own
studies that their employees were
accumulating this toxin in their blood
and they buried this information too
while their own employees developed
fatal cancers
so the cumulative health impact of
exposure to people through their
environment were never addressed when
companies like Dupont and 3M were
permitted to do business here in New
Hampshire we know better than to leave
the entirety of research of safety to
the companies who have Financial
interests as their primary directive not
our Public Health
it is prudent for us to ensure public
health and environmental safety and to
avoid the adverse economic impacts of
pollution by establishing appropriate
rules that take into account the
cumulative impacts of citing
manufacturing Recycling and waste sites
none of these things exist in a vacuum
and assessing a site permit in a silo is
an outdated and ineffective way to
address potential damage to the
communities they're located in
cumulative impacts results when the
effect of an action are added to or
interact with other effects in a
particular place and within a particular
time New Hampshire needs to invest in
giving the Department of Environmental
Services the resources they need to
dedicate a staff member to researching
cumulative impacts so will we learn from
our past will we recognize that without
strong rules and guardrails about
cumulative impacts
will we expect chemical companies to
protect our Public Health
that's like expecting Lucy to let
Charlie Brown kick the football
for the health of our people and the
environment of the state we love I
strongly urge the committee to recommend
Senate Bill 267 ought to pass and give
the Department of Environmental Services
the resources they need to help us
protect our Public Health thank you so
much for your time today thank you
Senator Earl Schiller I'm interested to
know if you believe
um that the report out date of June 30th
2025 is an adequate time frame
to produce the information that this
bill seeks
I
to be perfectly honest with you that was
a Compromise date I think it'd be I
personally think it could be done sooner
but sure June 2025 that's that's what
was um
that was the date that could get us all
here
thank you
oh the report out date and I'm sorry
you're correct because in section one it
says November 1st
2025. yeah it says the report uh Madam
chair the the 30 June 30 date is is the
appropriation
um interesting right okay so that
representative yeah so
um
uh I have a there are a couple of
questions that I have which are kind of
related in terms of potential amendments
and they're they're pretty tiny uh one
is that our committee is in fact not
listed on as a recipient of the report
and uh it would be nice to have our
committee uh listed as a report
recipient
um would you have any objection to that
I think that's an excellent idea
representative Bixby okay and the second
is that
um
a report out date of November 1st allows
for the Senate to write bills related to
it but that's after our bill writing
deadline so I was wondering if you might
be amenable to changing it to September
1st also an excellent idea the more
legislators who have opportunities to
write legislation protective of our air
water and soil
adds more voices to the table so I think
that's a great idea thank you thank you
representative detsee
ah thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
in reviewing this bill I went back to
the original bill which was 267 FN not
the event amended virgin I was surprised
to see that it was two and a half pages
long and quite detailed as opposed to
the amendment that I have in front of me
which is two paragraphs I also went back
and looked at the testimony that came
before the senate committee
and recognize that there were 130
individuals that signed in in support of
the original Bill and there were only
four people that were signed in to
oppose the bill uh when you had a second
committee meeting on it I believe there
were 55 people that signed in for uh in
support of the bill so my question is is
how did we get from a quite detailed
Bill two and a half pages to what I
considered to be a neutered bill of two
paragraphs
and I have a follow-up
um I thank you representative for your
question and thank you for outlining the
tremendous community support from all
over the state for the original
writing of 267 which also happened to
have included an incredibly large number
of stakeholders
as you described neutering of the bill
um
I would say that it was
hmm
assessing cumulative impacts was not
some members of our
legislature and
so we are
we are where we are today I
Madam chair disappointing but it is what
it is one follow-up okay thank you uh
one of the concerns that I have
um is basically uh
the commissioner
um
can move forward
are you in the first or the second
version I'm sorry yeah I'm I'm looking
at the amended Bill thank you okay and
I'm looking at lines one through four
yes and I won't read the whole thing but
what I'm concerned about is that
basically if I read that sentence it
indicates to me that it is within the
commissioner's purview to decide whether
or not something should be proposed okay
so that what guarantees does this
committee have that if we pass this
amendment that anything will happen
I mean because if I read this correctly
it's all within the commissioner's
purview can you address that
um thank you for the question you have
read that incredibly astutely
um
the commissioner does not make law
so
um representative bixby's
suggestions of bringing the report
to the legislature both committees on
both the house and the Senate is serve I
think well serves
New Hampshire
um
I would hope that the committee would
look at the original Bill's statement of
purpose and perhaps consider
moving that into any amendments that you
might write
and also your point of
legislative proposals being solely from
the commissioner might
might be a very narrow way to look at
this and that might be an amendment you
representative Haskins thank you madam
chair
thank you Senator lovely to see you here
today
um
I guess after uh representative Dusty's
comments I'd love to hear that you have
confidence that this you know somewhat
truncated no doubt compromise
ensued bill
um it's nice to see you too thank you
very much representative Haskins
to be perfectly honest with you what I
testify to that assessing what the
cumulative impacts are on our soil water
and air
matter
tremendously they don't exist
alone things that are put up into the
air often come down and affect the soil
we breathe them we eat food grown in
that soil we use that water to drink to
bathe to make products to make food and
so there is there is nothing that is not
thank you nothing that is not impacted
by something else and up until now we
have taken a very siled approach to
citing and assessing
um
how something might impact actually not
even how it might impact but
um how it would fit into a site permit
and it's we know better now we just we
have more information and we have also
um been
I would Hazard to say lied to by some of
the industries that have
um purposely obfuscated their own
research into the ways that they are
polluting and affecting our environment
and so if we don't take responsibility
for assessing what those cumulative
impacts may be from this site and this
site and this site and how it affects
our home
then shame on us
shame on us
so cumulative impacts absolutely needs
to be assessed if this gets us part of
the way there huzzah
is it as robust as I would have liked no
I am also not in the majority and have
the position to write Amendment so there
we are thank you senator
representing Bixby yeah so
um one uh
getting back to the question of uh the
commissioner uh being the uh essentially
the sole person listed here as uh uh who
would be recommending uh either rules or
legislation
um
is there would three do you think that
the
um the section one would create a report
that is sufficient to allow the
legislature to also make a judgment
about whether uh
whether there should be legislation
produced and uh is there some way that
that that if this wouldn't produce a
sufficient report that we could rephrase
this the paragraph one in order to make
sure that the report gave the
um thank you for the question uh
I see where you're going with that and
um I think you know
it is the it is the purview this bill
belongs to you now it's yours
um and if in the course of your
executive decision exact executive
session discussion
um that the committee feels a more
robust report delivered to the
legislature
um for the legislatures
decision making process about
determination of possible rules or
recommendations for rules or legislation
is more appropriate I
I I'm not going to be making phone calls
stopping that if that's what you're
asking for all right thank you
any further questions
thank you for your introducing this bill
to us today thank you very much I
appreciate it and I am now going to call
Craig Wright from Des to come and speak
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee uh through my years of service
I haven't been before this committee
very often usually I'm before St e but
it's certainly a pleasure to be here
today so
um I thought what I would do is I'll
introduce myself Craig Wright I serve as
the Director of the air Resources
Division at the Department of
Environmental Services also with me
today is Kathy beam
so if you if you stump me I may turn to
her with some of your questions so I
thought what I'd do is just kind of
describe a couple areas where in the
regulatory world where we're hearing
this term cumulative impact and what's
being done about it and then also give a
couple of examples of what a cumulative
impact analysis could be and then
certainly answer questions
so one of the first places we ever hear
about cumulative impact is at our local
permit hearings in communities this is
often an area that local citizens will
bring up because they feel it's an area
where we may not necessarily have the
regulatory scheme to address all
everything they would like to be
addressed in terms of our reviews of
that process
EPA has developed uh under what they
call environmental justice a number of
guidance memos on looking at cumulative
impact it's not very well defined at the
federal level there are no federal
regulations there's just guidance that
states should try to implement it
through their environmental justice
programs
the CDC center for the Disease Control
recently put out a tool they call their
environmental justice index and within
that system it's an online system where
you could go in type an address and it
tries to rank 36 different environmental
Public Health factors to come up with an
assessment of what type of cumulative
impact is in that community
there are a number of states across the
country that are looking at cumulative
impact analyzes and some are working
either in their permitting processes or
their rulemaking or actually have state
statutes that require some sort of
cumulative impact analysis some of those
states around us include Massachusetts
New Jersey Minnesota California and I'm
sure there's a number of other states
again a lot of attention at the federal
level
at the state level and at also the local
a couple quick examples of what
cumulative impact analyzes could be a
simple example on the air side is under
RSA 125i we have a state air toxics
program where we regulate over 600 a
toxics under that regulation and it's
implementing rules enva 1400 we
establish health-based standards for
those chemicals and what the
requirements are under that rule and
statute is that an individual facility
would need to demonstrate that at their
property boundary
through a tool we call Air dispersion
modeling that they're meeting that
standard at their property boundary and
Beyond
what the rule doesn't require is if you
have two facilities located near each
other they both need to demonstrate that
they meet that standard at their
respective property boundaries but it
does not look at where those emissions
could interact off property so that's
one easy example on a state side
um
a little more complicated on the air
side would be a what I would call a
combined analysis for different air
toxics for example again we have a
standard for I'm going to throw out the
a toluene as one air toxics we have one
standard for Benzene a facility needs to
demonstrate compliance with each one of
those individual standards but we do not
have a mechanism for say what if I'm a
little bit below on this one a little
bit below on that one what's the
combined impact right now we do not
require that analysis under the
regulatory framework that we have
um and the ultimate this goal I think is
Senate the senator mentioned is what is
the potential impact of cumulative
impacts on the environment in situations
where you could have error emissions you
could have what's in the water and we
drink the water we could have what's in
the soil and how does that impact human
health as well that would be the
ultimate level of cumulative impact um
I know there were some comments about
this being a stripped down bear uh bill
I would say that this is potentially a
significant change to the regulatory
framework
of house facilities are cited in New
Hampshire it doesn't it is a very
complicated science I think that
November one date uh to give the is to
give the department enough time to go
out and look at what is being proposed
in other states understand what they're
doing how they're making the assessment
of how do you measure the individual
impacts of different things and what is
the cumulative effect what is the
science behind that we would need to
consult internally with our
environmental health program to try to
get an understanding of that so there is
a lot of work in my opinion that would
need to go into this have some
reservations if you move that date up I
want to make sure the department has
time I understand the concern about
timing of filing legislation though so
um
so I think in the bottom line is I think
the department feels we didn't request
this bill we're kind of neutral on it
but if this is the path we want to go
down as a policy for the State of New
Hampshire
that I think doing a scoping study makes
a lot of sense you can't go at this
without a lot of sight foresight into
what you're doing and you need to make
sure you're using good science and
understanding what we're doing I will
stress that if we are to go down this
path we certainly need the staff person
I do not have the staff right now
necessary to undertake this we're
extremely short staffed as a department
and this is a whole new thing I will say
I'm the air director but this position
would be located probably in our
environmental health program which is in
the air division but it would really
interact with the waste and water
divisions as well so this is a thing
that we do now with the environmental
health program that's why we think that
would be the right place to put this
position that's probably more detail
than you need to know but that's where
we would likely do that so and with that
I can certainly try to answer questions
any questions from the committee
representative Murray
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
clarify uh thank you uh for taking my
question
um you did say that currently as it
stands you are not required if I had
have this correct to study the
relationship of two separate substances
yeah and how they interact with one
another yeah right now the the
regulatory framework of the states uh
air toxics regulation which is a pretty
comprehensive regulation we look at
compounds on an individual basis
thank you
representative Bixby yeah so um
do you feel that the end that if you did
not have uh this study the department
would have any capacity to make rules
based on cumulative impacts I would I
would say we need to do this study okay
definitively
uh my question is do you believe
if if we looked at this um November 2025
date and even we're thinking of putting
that back to September 1st so that there
would be some time for the house members
to submit legislation
um
feel that that is an adequate amount of
time to do this I mean it looks like
you're gonna have to need some time to
hire somebody to do it and then sit down
and do the actual work that that's sorry
so I'm just thinking do you do you think
perhaps we should push it out an extra
what's your thought on on time frame I I
think when we originally thought about
this we thought the November 1 time
frame of 2025 was sufficient
to give us the opportunity like you say
to create the position fill the position
as you know it's incredibly difficult to
fill positions in state government
I think this would be an attractive
position to somebody uh professionally
to be honest with you because it's kind
of Cutting Edge so I I think we would be
able to recruit somebody
um I think I'm comfortable within
November of 25 date okay
are you comfortable with a September
but I mean I I want to make sure that we
do the job correctly I mean in theory
um September 1 of 2025
assuming we have the position created by
this September gives us two years so
okay
if you told me I had to live with it I
would make it work okay
representative germano thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious in terms of I
absolutely appreciate uh as you're
saying how long it might take to to fill
a position but I'm wondering are there
regulatory models that you know of
already uh in in neighboring states for
example uh that do model for uh multiple
compounds in interaction in the scenario
that you described so I know the state
most closest state is the state of
Massachusetts is currently looking at a
cumulative impact analysis but it's
strictly on the air toxic side right now
they're not necessarily looking at air
water and waste but that's the most
closest one I think there's still about
they're probably a year into their
rulemaking process and I think they plan
to finish by the end of this year so
it's about a two-year process for them
thank you thank you madam chair any
other questions representative Bixby so
um would you invit do you envision this
position being there for the two years
that we that that are allotted in this
bill and then disappearing or do you see
this as something that would be an
ongoing uh
an ongoing piece of work in the
department I would cons I would most
likely think it would be an ongoing
piece of work in the department so cons
follow up yep so conceivably we could
have a report out date of September 1st
2025 and then we would could expect
further reports
um on a so semi-annual or annual Justice
absolutely and that would allow us and
then so you know the the whole work may
not be done by September uh 2025 but uh
that may be a point at which you know a
few things would be recognized that okay
we need to do legislation on this yes I
thank you seeing none I now call Roger
Stevenson to come and testify
in support of this bill and you
that's
my name is Roger Stevenson I live in
Stratham New Hampshire I'm the regional
director for advocacy for the climate
and energy program
at the union of concerned scientists an
organization with half a million members
supporters including 2800 here in New
Hampshire
UCS supports 267 with one change to the
timeline
and I'm here to tell you there is
science to sue to support
Senate bill 267. it's well known and
documented that people are exposed to
multiple chemicals at once
not one at a time from a single Source
the way many environmental regulatory
rules are written
we're exposed to pollutants by breathing
eating and by touch with our skin
this means that there needs to be cross
linkages
in environmental permitting between
water air and the soil for example
exposures to mixtures of chemicals
versus single chemicals can produce
different or Worse impacts
there is a scientific approach
informing how to combine qualitative
data such as information and feedback
from communities
and quantitative data such as numbers
and measurements this approach has been
evolving since the 80s and provides
support to implement this bill and we
would encourage
if the department were to undergo a
scoping study that members of different
communities were included in that
analysis on a qualitative basis
so what does this mean well I think
you've already heard that New
Hampshire's environmental regulatory
system needs to reflect these realities
Senate Bill 267 is a critical First Step
because right now we have a regulatory
system that has not evolved to address
cumulative impacts
we recommend the timeline be changed and
to November 2024. we asked that the
timeline for reporting and assessment be
reduced mapping tools ample data
examples from other states experiences
are available for the Department to
modify and supplement in order to report
findings and propose any proposed
legislation or rule making well before
November first 2025.
we should not have to wait two years
Dr Devin Payne Sturgis a doctor of
Public Health at the University of
Maryland School of Public Health
specializes in cumulative environmental
health risks and he says
the cumulative risks and impacts
represent the biggest silent regulatory
policy failure that is robbing us of our
physical cognitive and mental health and
well-being
the new school has done extensive
research on the proposed and enacted
cumulative impacts policies in the
United States I reference that here in
my notes and 13 states have legislation
mapping tools and or agency guidance
documents that include consideration of
cumulative impacts
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and I've included three blog posts from
a colleague Christy ellickson an expert
in cumulative impacts on the last page
thank you sir any questions
thank you for coming to testify on this
thank you
good morning chair Aaron and honorable
committee members my name is Noah
Bosworth and I am the relatively new
zero waste staff attorney for the
conservation law Foundation
we are here to enthusiastically support
this bill
the while the science behind cumulative
impacts analysis or assessment can be
complex the reason for having this bill
in the first place is quite simple which
is that a facility individually on its
own May satisfy permitting requirements
and not pose a clear risk of harm but
when multiple facilities and sources of
pollution affect a community the
cumulative impact impacts can become
quite harmful
we do like others uh urge the uh
timeline to be a bit shorter we would
argue that the commissioner should
report the findings six months earlier
by May 2025
and as has been stated
the agency does not have to reinvent the
wheel here New Jersey Massachusetts and
New York have all
begun or already implemented uh
laws that have resulted in similar
regulations as this agency would be
looking into
and
we believe that particularly because
that initial report would be the first
of an ongoing series of reports it is
feasible and valuable to create a
shorter timeline that would result in
really thoughtful legislation being on
the table
by September 2025.
so I'm keeping it short and I just
full-heartedly support this legislation
and I urge the committee to vote ought
to pass
any questions from the committee
sure representative Murray go ahead
thank you madam chair could we just have
either an electronic copy of your
statements or a copy or is that just
general notes or so I will be testifying
later on SB 61 and I have plenty of
copies but I um we decided that I would
only testify oily on this particular
bill thank you
okay any other questions or comments on
this
is anybody else wish to speak on this
bill
on SB 267.
seeing none I'm looking for the blue
online so the uh online portal says 53
support one neutral
you have one person signed up in support
since there's no further comment on this
I am going to close the hearing on sb267
thank you for coming in to uh testify
and introduce this bill today
we are now going to take a recessive
break until
12 30 when we will be hearing SB 62
we would have one announcement real
quick
uh thank you madam chair on uh SB 159
the landfill uh permit committee there
were 58 people online that were
supportive with zero against I I missed
that last time okay sure
so we are going to recess for lunch and
come back at 12 30 for uh SB 62. thank
you very much everyone for sitting in
foreign
whatsoever
a little shot
please
legislation
um
we would do some things not everything
you want but and we're concerned about
the
how robust the process is
we know it's perfectly fine
independent outside somebody that knows
about the same history that's not tied
to
it doesn't have a financial interest in
confidence here we're uh we're very
interested in
Public Schools but I think if we could
live with this if it was if it's an
event
but uh like everything else it's not
like to get anywhere
being willing to give me that I think
the dentist will probably be supportive
yes yeah
I never in a million years thought I
came from a testified for solid waste
so the two things that you know we just
think conflict of interest is a concern
and uh the weather feels really it's not
like we're we've got garbage lining up
unless we've got plenty of capacity so
let's just let the study play out and
we'll just see how
open their hearts into that
unfortunately working back and we're
talking to people
so we'll see yeah it's a
but we're you know unfortunate we have a
lot of people who like to tell me I
it's so it's one of those things we have
to just it's a PowerPoint I love it yeah
yeah
energy around them
yeah I mean I think we've learned that
uh
a lot of it isn't the Merit of the bill
it's the politics and behind it you know
and we're fighting things that we don't
even understand I don't know why it's a
new production support the environment
but he's he's a smart guy
I think it would be a feather in his cap
and say you know I think one of these
speakers
I don't understand he has to be willing
to an age and we have to be careful
which is like a little about this
um
thank you
to me it's like it's just it shouldn't
another story about how dangerous
and it's not the way it's involved I
mean it's just what's in all the product
but they're the ones who want to
build another one of these behemoth Y
and what really pisses most of us off
it's it's this would never go in it
wasn't promising internship it wasn't
for solving Massachusetts and now
Connecticut
their their you know Solid Waste
problems
yeah
of taking this one this is like one
small little
you know regulations that's taken five
years
and the truth is there's many other
things to have solid-based here the
Karen email and some of the work that
anyone together a lot of other things
the real word should be
stop
do a better job we should start pushing
back on the manufacturers philosophical
graphics
that's where we'd like for the state to
be
hopefully
it's do they have the world to think
about
this this feelings
Far Cry
56.
foreign
okay
yeah
foreign
again
yes
foreign
Seafood
it's like a wedding or something I can
okay
short answer yes awesome
I have not been able to get into it yet
so my wife and my kids are in it but I'm
foreign
good afternoon everyone welcome to
environment agriculture
and it is
12 31 we are going to get started with
Senate Bill 62 our hearing uh relative
to landowner liability under RSA 147 B
the Hazardous Waste cleanup fund
and
Senator avard was supposed to be here
this afternoon to introduce this bill
but he is not here so we will be
listening to Grant bossy
thank you madam chair members of the
committee Senator Evart sends his best
he and his appendix are having a mutual
parting of the ways yes uh I'm Grant
bossy from the New Hampshire Senate here
to introduce Senate Bill 62 on behalf of
Senator Kevin avard the bills Prime
sponsor the Department of Environmental
Services asked Senator rabar to bring in
this bill cleaning up a drafting error
that's been sitting in statute for about
a decade this law ensures that
landowners are not liable for pollution
on their land caused by God war or
somebody else
we should hold polluters responsible for
their actions but not punish innocent
landowners for acts of third parties
existing law refers to hazardous
substances but should more accurately
reference hazardous waste or hazardous
materials sb62 also replaces a few
pronouns with proper nouns to prevent
any confusion on who is meant by the
statute this does not change the state's
liability policy SB 62 received
unanimous support of the senate
committee on energy and natural
resources and passed on the consent
calendar I would defer any questions to
the department if you have them or I can
get them to Senator Evart Senator ever
thanks for consideration and support of
Senate bill 62.
um
I guess or you are you did you say you
were taking questions I uh if you have
questions for Senator Evart I can write
them down and get you an answer but I'm
not the right person does anyone have
any questions
no thank you thank you all right I will
now call director Mike wimsat from NHD
yes good afternoon
um
thank you madam chair nice to be here
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is Mike winsat I
serve as director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Des I appreciate the opportunity to
testify in support of Senate Bill 62
this afternoon as Mr bossy indicated
this was a request to the department and
we of course we support the bill and it
is really about cleaning up some
language that has been an error in the
statute for some time so as Mr bossy
indicated uh RSA 147b establishes
liability Provisions related to releases
of hazardous waste or hazardous
materials at properties it also provides
for defenses and limits on liability of
landowners particularly at 147 b10a
and unfortunately when the when this was
drafted some time ago
um the term hazardous substance was used
in some places where really it should
have said hazardous waste and hazardous
materials
um and and that is what we're seeking to
fix with this bill how's this substance
is not defined in the statute and in
fact it has some important meanings in
other state and federal laws but it
really doesn't have a place in this
particular section of the law so its use
is really just misplaced here and needs
correction
none of these changes as Mr bossy
indicated changed the meaning or the
principal intent of this law but it will
serve to avoid confusion in the future
application of the law and with that
I'll leave it there and be happy to take
any questions great
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much I
appreciate you coming to explain this to
us thank you
all right is there anyone else who would
like to speak on SB 62
seeing none yes thank you for passing up
the blue sheet one and one
um we had one in support and one in
opposition on the online portal
so with that I'm going to close out the
hearing on SB 62 that was short and
sweet
and give that to you
and
um in about 10 minutes we will continue
I can't start before then
um we will continue with SB 61 for the
all right um we have a 12 45 now and I
would like to open up the hearing on SB
61.
and in here today this afternoon to
introduce the bill is Senator David
Waters welcome to environment
agriculture well thank you so much Madam
chair members of the committee uh
Senator David Waters District Four and
I'm here for Senator avard is not here
today and uh so since he and I are the
co-sponsors on this legislation I'm very
happy to uh to introduce the bill and
um you know I'd like to walk through
some of the visions and certainly we
have uh Des folks here and others to
address some of the technical process
that's envisioned here in terms of the
rulemaking that will be undertaken for
the landfill setbacks but
um I would like to start by just noting
where we are and that
um this issue uh is of extraordinary
importance to the legislature and to the
people of New Hampshire and I and I do
think that we have actually made a lot
of progress over the last few years we
we did the 10-year uh plan we've got the
solid way study committee for all the
source reduction work that we have to do
and we have been trying very hard over
the last couple of sessions to do
something about citing and setback rules
and uh you know we were all deeply
involved or most of us here and
certainly in the senate in 1454
um you made changes to that bill we made
changes to that bill and it passed and I
got vetoed and so what uh has been done
since that time in both bodies with
House Bill 56 which I also co-sponsored
in this one I've tried to understand
what that process taught us and how it
can move forward because I think there's
a deeply shared commitment uh in the
Senate with you all that we've got to do
something we really we do have to
address this issue and um so I am
presenting you what is the Senate
position on it and I I wanted to
emphasize that kind of shared purpose
here and the desire to get something
done this session because if you look
through the purpose statement and a lot
of the principles in this you're going
to see things that are actually very
similar to what was in House Bill 56 I
mean who who Among Us would disagree
protection of perennial rivers lakes and
Coastal Waters from contamination is in
the public interest of the State of New
Hampshire I mean that that's why we're
here that's why we have these these
bills and then starting on line seven
and eight the purpose here is to
establish site-specific setbacks and
that's again what we recognize is what
we must do moving forward and again both
bills have that's basically the
principles that they have um started
from and uh you know certainly we know
from the hard experience we've had with
pbass that we have to have all hands on
decked in the legislature and then you
know certainly DES in developing the
rules and procedures and the limits that
have been developed for p fast that show
so we we can do this we can do this um I
think for this as well because we know
we've done it in other areas as well
now um just to start going through a
little bit of the of again the findings
um do note
um that the hydrological investigation
that's one thing that came very clear to
me through 1454. we don't have the
science and sometimes understand
the the groundwater we I think we're
pretty good on runoff but groundwater we
don't know groundwater flows and the
issue of how far a setback should be and
what is the permeability and how fast
contaminants might potentially move and
what are the mitigation things all that
needs to be termed by this hydrological
study um and um
but regardless the 200 foot setback is
preserved in this this bill as a
Baseline and then the setback from that
is what this bill uh is is about and um
if you continue on on the page
uh two
um
kind of setting the context of what are
the most protective methods we need and
how we're going to get there
in rule making again as in 56 the
principle here starting in lines 10 and
10 through 12 on page two
um that there may be design features
that are needed to increase redundancy
yes I think there's a lot of broad
agreement on that that you know that
there are new techniques and new
methodologies and design features that
that can help out here and we want to
make sure that's part of this
consideration as as well then the
approach that the Senate has taken is to
do the is to do as part of rulemaking
rather than preemptively setting the
requirements for this which was the
methodology that was vetoed by the
governor so you'll see starting on lines
26 uh again this should look quite
similar to what was in
um House Bill 56 because it's these very
categories that we're being used in
terms of deciding what kind of
variations in the time frame might be
permitted in the sighting as well so
travel time of groundwater in line 27 I
mean that's very much at the heart of
the bills that both of our bodies um
have have had
and then down at the bottom of the page
again now in the rule making that
statute about what are greater and more
redundant protections uh for perennial
um Waters and that continues on to page
three uh these again shall look quite
familiar they're the kinds of things
that house bill 56 had as as well about
the kind of redundancies and
technologies that can be used there
and then getting into the procedures of
then after the rules are made how will
the department actually deal with
applications and
this starts down in section five
um and uh the timelines there
um and and so forth and then the
criteria for review starting on page
four which as you might expect the
criteria here park back to those things
that I've already pointed out about
the bill uh already about uh
recommendations on factors and criteria
um and and so forth
um and then
I know of great interest here starts on
Section six uh how long is this rule
making gonna take
can it get done uh in time and what
happens if applications come in during
the rulemaking period these are
important issues they've been of
importance to you they are they were to
us we worked hard on this in the Senate
with the Department to say okay what is
a time frame that can actually work and
we can have some assurance that the
rules will be done in this time frame so
there's not that trigger that if you
don't do it in two years then somebody
can be in under their old rules and we
didn't want that we wanted to make sure
that the rules got done and if a
proposal came in during that two-year
period it was held in advance
and then had to be judged by these new
rules now the question might still be
out there will they really get it done
and I would look back to the experience
we just had with the rulemaking under
the 10-year plan you know that was a
pretty hard deadline that representative
Ebel and I put in that bill in 315 to
get that done and they did it they did
it and so I you'll hear you can ask that
of the department but the reason we went
with this time frame was the reason we
went with holding who's in advance is
our sense that this actually this can
actually uh actually work so let me
continue on if I may uh to page five
and uh here again making very clear
that uh proposal that's come in in these
two years is held in advance and then uh
it does say that if it's not done within
24 months the rules aren't they can go
under the old rules
I think this has to be there but
um I don't I don't I hope that never
happens
um then the last part of the section
seven this was Senate Bill 227 which I
introduced in response to the
recognition that we did not have good
groundwater studies and hydrological
information and we decided to fold
Senate Bill 227 in the Senate Bill 61
and here as you'll see there's an
appropriation of 150 000 dollars
that is made so that an independent um
scientists can be
consultant can come in
I will note that this is something that
the state agencies do all the time
and it is of course important to make
sure that said consultant is unbiased
and can do the kind of scientifically
based work that is going to inform some
of the Judgment there so Madam chair I'm
sorry to walk through it I know you can
all read and all that but given the
importance of this issue for you I just
want to make it very clear
um how to send it up ended up where it
did and I'd be glad to take any
questions no I thank you very much for
your detailed introduction it's very
helpful are there questions from the
committee
representative coulon
excuse me thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my questions
Senator Waters I notice in comparing
this bill with some of the other bills
that have passed through this committee
it really doesn't lay out uh specific
kind of numbers do you think this will
help combat uh legislative
incrementalism
uh in the future
well thanks for your question I I think
that the heart of your question is the
rulemaking process which is the
legislative process and you know I've
been on gel car a number of times
probably some of you have as as well and
um so that to me is where that issue
gets addressed that it's the rulemaking
um then and this the spirit of the
Senate bill is looking at what has been
done in other states that is the
rulemaking process which is the
legislative process where those those
really specific things will be addressed
but do note on the bill I think it's
pretty clear what the guard rails are
and what the criteria are and that's why
I wanted to go through them because
they're kind of like what what was in
454 and 56 actually
um you know to say that these are these
are the these are the things on which
the rules will be made and that's where
the real specifics will come in does
that answer your question kind of or uh
yeah good enough all right thank you
representative germana
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking my question so as we
discussed in detail when we uh heard HB
56 right we're talking about a a 30 year
old kind of process at this point
looking at the rules that are currently
in place so and we're looking at 24
months uh in order to conduct this
process of looking into new rules
you may not be the best person to ask
this question but I'll ask it anyway
um do you have a sense of what it is
more that we need to be looking for I
mean what are the outstanding scientific
issues that the past 30 years have not
educated us on and what's an extra two
years going to do in terms of providing
great Revelations about what this
process is supposed to be well thanks
and I I know the department will talk
about that but here's here's my take on
it we did anybody even heard of pfas 30
years ago anybody even heard of
cumulative effects 30 years ago
um did we have the kind of Technologies
we have now for double and triple lining
and Wells to be drilled and trying to
determine
um permeability and and so on a lot has
changed both in in our our sense of the
necessity of having rules that are
adequate
to deal with the actual materials that
are there uh and um you know that and
provide the kind of kind of protections
that we we need so I think that um
there's a lot to be said and and I again
will look to the example of the
rulemaking that was around the 10-year
plan
the bill was not all that complicated
but it said make the rules on various
things and the rules are extensive now
the rule process if they come into gel
car and folks say think that you really
didn't get her you didn't cover
everything that that's another
legislative opportunity to make sure we
get it right
follow-up follow-up I appreciate that
thank you and I guess my question then
is given all of those technological
advancements what we know now that we
didn't know then do you have a sense of
why it is that our rules have not kept
pace with you know why are we at this
point because it seems to me that all of
those developments are new but they're
not brand new so why have they not
already been Incorporated and what is 24
months going to do that the past say 10
years hasn't
well thanks for the question and um
you know I think Solid Waste really
emerged over the last 10 12 years as a
much more significant issue for all all
the New England states that own across
the country and I think we became to
recognize that business as usual both in
um trying to have waste reduction and
then also dealing with the new and
dangerous potentials chemical leaks I
mean who knew you know 30 40 years about
about Coakley who knew
right now we know
so I I think I have real confidence that
um we will be informed and we will
create good rules and why I mean I've
been around for 14 years so I guess I
got to blame myself a little bit but uh
you know um I'm glad now we're going to
address it thank you Senator thank you
madam chair yeah representative Bixby
so um one aspect of department rules is
that they uh get retired on a particular
schedule and uh is it correct that the
um the sighting rules for landfills are
um I'm you know we had some legislation
about this last year I don't remember
but I asked the department on that okay
thanks and I I will say my own
legislative take on it is that if rules
expire that they they can ask for them
to be a continuance in jail car which I
think would be appropriate under here
and the safety in this bill is that
let's say those rules are continued we
have said that anything comes in under
those rules we have to be reevaluated
when these rules are done
all right
so um one of the things that I'm
concerned about is
um is that the the 24 months and uh I
have seen uh Des effectively uh complete
rules uh within on a fairly tight
schedule I have also seen them Miss
Rules by about six years uh and need to
be Pro further prodded um and uh so I uh
I
I am really worried about the idea that
if we these rules are not completed uh
within 24 months that on the
that the the rules then automatically go
back to what we have now which uh we
know there are some problems with uh so
um
would you see a uh
um what would your take be on uh
amending the bill so that uh the uh
there's still a 24 month deadline but
the result of missing that deadline is
not going back to the old rules
well thanks for your question and um you
know in general Madam chair uh we
understand the Senate doesn't always get
it perfect or even right and if there
are some things that could still Garner
the support of the Senate and the and
the governor and others that uh that
make some sense I will note in that you
know we talked a lot about the 24 and
what time would be needed and one thing
that I felt at that time and discussed
in our executive session a little bit
was that you know this gives us
another legislative session
that if we see the rules or not
happening or there's some uncertainty
about it we can put the you know we can
raise the hammer and put it down pretty
hard uh next next session so I I I I I
hear you I mean I was really worried
about the tenure Solid Waste planning
whether those rules get done and by God
they did it but you know it's it's as
important for us to keep on it as a
legislature and we ultimately have the
power um to pass another bill
that's a good point
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair and um thank you
senator for the work that went into this
bill
I confess that I'm disappointed that 56
didn't make it it was a good bill and
I'm hoping that we can make 61 even
better
I'm concerned about the reversion to the
old rule just as
representative Bixby said I think we
need to tighten that language so that
it's really clear that we can't go back
to that the 30 year old rule isn't good
enough for what we now know and we can
do better so I think you know we can
look forward to amending the language
that way I'm concerned about protection
I think this is the most important bill
that I have been asked to weigh in on in
my first term in the legislature I have
some experience
um
dealing with industry on the Seacoast
and I know that we need Independence we
need our government to be responsible to
its citizens so I'm going to be looking
for ways that we can
increase what might look like adequate
protection to ample or better protection
the best that we can make it
um
so when you said you hope it never
happens I think we have to ensure that
if it does we have a contingency in
place but I do thank you for the work
that went into it well thank you for
your comments and um you know I think
that implicit there are some questions
you're going to be asking the folks from
Des yes
thank you any other questions for
Senator Waters representative Dotsy
yes thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
I have to say when I read this bill I I
found it to be a head scratcher okay
um a probably 30 to 40 years ago there
was a company called WR Grace in Woburn
Massachusetts
um that had uh polluted the water the
groundwater in Woburn uh seriously there
were a lot of cancer clusters there and
a huge amount of geological uh
geohydrology was done to understand the
groundwater and how those toxins were
dispersed in in that area so we already
I mean and I don't think that water
movement changes that much over 40 years
okay I mean maybe the way we detect it
and maybe we're a little bit more
sophisticated but water moves where
water wants to move and that's happened
we already had a bill 56 that looked at
the hydrogeology and came up with
recommendations
and we could get working on it right
away so I'm really questioning why
if we have at least 40 Years of data
and we know how water moves and we had a
bill that addressed this why we're
kicking the can down the road two more
years
I I think that I disagree and this is
why I put Senate Bill 227 in which got
Incorporated here in the statement that
we know how water moves yeah I mean we
know how water moves it seeks the lowest
level but we do not know in particular
sites
particularly one in the North Country
which is much the subject of a lot of
concerns exactly what the groundwater
does when you get deep down under there
and I think that that's where when the
idea is site-specific is we want to make
sure we know how the water is Flowing at
that site and I was not convinced that
we really did and that we needed to know
so I think this bill is a twofer yes
when you're evaluating the application
there is a hydrological assessment at
that time
but this gives a tool to Des
and some funding
to do studies of hydrogeology and
groundwater
that can help inform them scientifically
so they're prepared for what might be
the size specific
so that would be my difference here is I
I don't think we really do know and if
we're going to have site specific we
better really know about that site about
where the groundwater might go and how
fast it might get there and I was I'm
just not convinced we really actually
know that
no
um oh go ahead yeah no for me I um I
think this is a really good
a really good bill and um
I thank you and and your committee for
for working on it and putting the time
and effort and thought into it as well
thank you very much and obviously
Senator Evart will be back and I'm
around for any questions but uh you'll
get the real facts are probably people
behind us thank you thank you very much
oh I'm sorry one question from uh
representative Potenza so I just have a
question about
um you're saying that these rules in
section three and four will be
interpreted by JL Carr when would that
happen so let's just say that this
passes what's what's that process I know
we have a deadline saying when they have
to have it done by which
so what does this look like
um that's a question and um you know Des
will be able to tell you in terms of
this specific rulemaking what a timeline
will look like but in general what
happens is the department
either has rule renewal or a bill like
this asks them to make rules under 541a
and then they they they work on the
rules they do the scientific work and
all the staff work they have to do and
Consultants maybe sometimes and they
bring that then to get on the um agenda
for gel car and then the gel car process
is that the gel car attorneys work on
the rules to make sure they comply um
legally with requirements and rules and
so on and so forth and then they are
brought to gel car and gel car has
public hearing and then it can decide to
accept uh ask for revision or reject
rules and then the department can bring
them back in
um but that that process is kind of laid
out under under gel cards very thorough
yep follow-up yeah I'm familiar with the
gel call process I just feel as if
um
all of the work that's been done on this
which I'm new on this committee so
there's been a lot of work and the
subject has been you know there's a lot
of Representatives that are here that
have done a lot of work on this so and
that have been waiting for this for a
long time
it's just jail cars operating within its
own so where what experts are they using
you're saying that outside people are
coming in to do all of that to setting
these rules so because they're not
arbitrary but it's really not coming
back to the committee that's really been
working on this in the house they're
well thanks for the question and you
know um gel Carr is a legislative it's a
legislative committee
and I don't know if any members on this
committee are on it but it's a large
legislative Committee of house and and
uh and Senate um members and five and
five yep yeah and uh and so
it is it is a legislative committee and
um you can ask particularly about what
the expectations are from Des about the
process the rule making we're looking at
the Des what they're going to do to do
the rulemaking here but that's why we
did the two years because originally
we're thinking of a tighter timeline and
we were told by Des we can't do this
right unless we have the and but we are
confident in two years so that's that's
why that that timeline is in here but do
ask them about their their what they
imagine the process here of this
rulemaking will be okay I will thank you
thank you representative Bixby just a
little clarification in terms of gel car
uh there are two ways that
um this committee could potentially have
input one is that uh a member of gel
Carr might see this might see rules
coming up related to this bill and
consult with us because they know that
we went through the process with this
bill uh and uh the other is that the
speaker's office is now publishing on a
bi-weekly basis the bills that are the
rules that are coming up before gel car
so we'll we will be alerted to when
these rules are going to be considered
and we can approach members of gel car
okay thank you
uh thank you Senator Waters
the next person I'd like to call up
cription
understand
the chairman
thank you
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee um for the record my name
is Mike Wimsatt a service director of
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services Waste Management
Division and I forget I forgive me I did
not put it on the card but joining me
today is our assistant commissioner Mark
Sanborn
and I appreciate the opportunity to come
and testify on Senate bill 61.
um the department does support this bill
uh we the the bill would amend and I I
it's hard to improve on Senator Waters
very thorough uh introduction in the
bill but you know as stated it amends
our say 149 M to direct the agency to
adopt rules that establish criteria for
setting site-specific setback surface
water setbacks for landfills and of
course it also directs us to contract
for an outside party a call qualified
contractor to assess our current rules
and make any recommendations for uh
changes or improvements to those rules
as this committee knows perhaps better
than anyone this issue has been a topic
of great interest for the general court
and for the public for a number of years
now and we believe that this bill is
going to be an effective way of
addressing the topic and we support it
um essentially as Senator Waters
indicated
we're to consider in our rule making
um hydrogen hydrogeologic
characteristics and conditions that is
specific to a site and and describe how
those will be used to determine what an
appropriate site-specific setback might
be for a landfill we're also to consider
certain uh Beyond compliance if you will
or additional technologies that could be
applied at a given site that might
influence what would be considered a
safe setback distance for that site but
importantly this this this report that
we're to contract for uh will really
bring in a third-party contractor to
really take an eyes open look at our
current regulations you know probably
look at you know we would anticipate
them also reviewing neighboring states
regulations and basically review that
and make recommendations for where they
might see those our current rules
lacking and how they might be improved
upon so what we anticipate has been to
discussed is that this 24-month period
from passage of the bill it's a Target
date for for this rulemaking we have
every and anticipation and expectation
that we will meet that that Target
deadline and uh we would what we would
do is we'd immediately work to get if
the bill were to pass immediately get a
Contracting process going get a
Contractor on board with an expectation
that the report from that contractor
would come in the fall of 24 and that
that would help to inform our rulemaking
process which we would uh you know then
early in 25 we would anticipate filing
an initial proposal for rulemaking which
would put us on a trajectory to have a
rules finalized by the summer of 25
which would be that 24-month period so
with that I'll turn it over to our
assistant commissioner
thanks Mike
um afternoon everyone appreciate the
opportunity
um I've been asked to clarify the
Department's position on a couple
amendments Etc so I'll just quickly do
that uh the director already mentioned
one
um Mr Sanborn we have no amendments
at this time I may clarify a few points
some positions of the department
regarding this bill okay but we we have
no amendments on that yes committee has
no amendments on this bill at this time
I understood Madam chair just uh let me
just make a few broad uh General points
about uh the position of the department
um the director already mentioned one we
intend the scope to include neighboring
states and a review of that
um when the study is published uh we
were very open to public comments and
reactions to those and
um uh and plus there will be opportunity
during the rule making for any public
comments
um
and
the uh oh and we will ensure there's no
conflict of interest in their Provisions
in the contract to make sure there won't
be conflicts of interest down the line
um on the issue of of a potential of not
having a 24 month time period and that
being removed and it being opened ended
the department does have concerns with
that potential that could artificially
prolong the rulemaking process in a way
that we don't feel would be beneficial
um so we want to build a pass we this
has been going on for multiple sessions
and we're ready to move on with a rule
making
SB 61 that's currently amended the
version in front of you the department
can support and I have every confidence
and expectation that it would make it
through and be signed into law any
changes to it puts that in danger
so I just throw that out to you I I we
want to see something pass the version
in front of you I know can happen
any changes to it I fear would derail
that and we'd end up with another
um so I have a question for you or for
director wimsat with regard to the RFP
process and how what What mechanisms do
you have in your RFP process maybe you
can just describe the process to us
which will ensure that there's no
conflict of interest in any third party
that you would employ to do this study
so I'm gonna let the director run
through what we'll use for RPG just
remember to include we're going to take
public comments on scope
sure thank you for the question so what
we anticipate is that you know we we do
do a fair amount of solicitations for
contractors uh often on a qualifications
based selection process for engineering
and hydro geologists
um we hire a number of contractors we
have them on board at any given time for
that kind of work so we would anticipate
following a similar process where we put
out a request for proposals that would
provide
um a responsive uh parties to provide
their uh summary of their qualifications
in a proposal for completing the work as
described in the in the bill or in the
law and then based on that we would
likely put together a panel of Des staff
who would then uh you know to the extent
we have a large number of applicants we
would narrow down to based on the
qualifications packages
and proposals a certain number that we
would interview and then we would
interview them and then make a selection
based on that process and then we would
anticipate that you know as is always
been the case we we deal with when we're
hiring contractors we always have to be
concerned about about conflict of
interest when we normally are you know
letting a contract it may be for a
specific project in which case we would
evaluate conflicts specific to that
project right at the outset or in many
of the contracts we let are broad
contracts which we don't necessarily
even know what the projects will be so
once they're on board we will generally
vet those when we're trying to select
which contractor will do a particular
job we would evaluate conflicts
potential conflicts of interest during
that process for this one we know what
the topic is so we would be able to
evaluate that on the front end and we
would anticipate that that would be we
would expect them to address the
question of any potential conflicts in
their proposals and then the app the
interview process we'd be able to
explore that if we have any concerns
about it and then we can make a decision
yeah so I would note
um that as the bill is constructed right
now when we put together a draft request
for proposals that draft Tower of P
would go out for public comment before
we actually issue it so there would be
an opportunity for the public to comment
on the content of that request and then
what would you do with the comment when
you receive it oh we would consider
those comments and and and and as we do
it often with comments we may amend the
document to reflect and address those
comments
thank you any questions representative
Creighton
hi yep
uh thank you madam chair
um thank you director the um
as I look at at uh page five under line
seven it has you going back if if a
contract is not done in 24 months
those
um projects that were held in the Bands
then go back to current rules
um to me I mean I always like to going
into a contract understand it's going to
be completed in the time and that if
it's not then there's consequences well
this
it says there's no consequences if it's
not done and and so what's the assurance
that this has been done in 24 months
well I I read that wrong sure that's a
great question what I can assure you is
that the importance and the value of
this work
um on the part of the general court in
the public is not at all lost on the
agency we will do everything in our
power to make sure that we get the
contract let promptly and get the report
promptly and that we then
um Undertake and we will be we will be
concurrently working on our rulemaking
and basically a a format for that with
the idea that it could be that it will
be informed by the report once it's
available and then we'll make sure that
we have a proposal an initial proposal
for rulemaking which is the first
official step in rulemaking filed early
in 25 so that we'll be on a trajectory
to have those rules completed by the
yeah yeah and so
um
under that line seven then is there a
reason that it has to be in the bill
you see what I'm talking about Oh you
mean with respect to what happens if the
rules are not made right I I think
that's in there because it's a I mean
this bill represents uh you know I've
described it as basically a boat that
everybody could get on it was a build it
was intended to have the support of all
the parties who have an interest in this
and I think that parties who might be
interested in filing a permit
application don't want a completely
open-ended process where by
they might never have never have an
opportunity to have their permit
application reviewed and decided on
under the rules so I think it represents
a compromise of the parties to get
language that everybody could get behind
I mean very candidly I think that's what
it represents okay thank you
I just want to quickly add
um a part of the the way this bill is
written is there some level of trust and
faith that Des is going to be able to do
our job
and
believe I believe we we were the ones
who uh proposed to the folks involved
that we could do this in 24 months if we
didn't think we could do it we know this
that we know how scrutinized this
process will be how much everyone has
put into this so
um we we are going to do everything to
do we're going to move process
concurrently where we can we are going
to meet the 24 months so
um and and that's the only balance to
being able to get folks who come from
different perspectives on this a
timeline is necessary because an
open-ended just won't work for the other
side
both of you for taking my question I did
have a question again about RFP in the
event that um you get one uh or have
trouble even getting posted let's say
that that would happen What would the
other process be if you don't have a
large pool of applicants
well we certainly we think that there
are there there is a a relatively large
pool of applicants in the region who
would be qualified to do this kind of
work so we don't anticipate having a a
terribly small
a pool of applicants but our
expectations as long as we have
responsive applicants whatever number
that is that we believe are qualified we
will interview and make a selection
representative Haskins
thank you madam chair
um so I just want to clarify something I
was confused by Mr sanborn's comments
that
um a certain Amendment or alteration
would put the bill in danger
and I want to understand that my role I
believe our role is to make
law
and then do the very best we can to be
responsible to our constituents and then
give it to you folks to do the rule
making so we will do our job without
fear or favor
and I wanted to make sure that was
understood sure my comment was based on
the fact
um
I am very confident that this could go
all the way through including having the
governor support the bill as written and
as amended the current version of the
bill any alteration of that and
um
I am concerned that and have been
authorized to let folks know that a
concerned that it could make it all the
way through the this process
and with respect sir that's not my
concern oh no it doesn't have to be I'm
just here to let folks know I've been we
have gone through this process over the
last couple of months where we have been
given the fact that of how close the
bill came last session a bill came and
it ended up being vetoed by the governor
and and not moving forward we have been
asked to be as clear as possible about
what we believe is a bill Des can
support and something that can have the
support all the way so it can become law
and so we are being as transparent as
possible every time we get up about
what what has the possible what we
believe has the possibility of
successfully being making it through the
whole process and I am confident the
current version of the bill would be
able to do that amendments at this point
would
be a challenge to be able to see
something successfully happen this
session
representative Bixby thank you madam
chair uh so what is uh if this bill does
not pass
then uh how will so I believe that that
the current rules expire in 2020 in July
uh so uh how do you how Des deal with uh
the rulemaking on this if this bill does
not pass
thanks for the question so you're
correct the the solid waste rules as a
group and they are inch and a half thick
um with about 21 chapters
um do expire on July 1 of 2024. we have
embarked on a uh rule making uh plan
that includes taking a few chapters at a
time one of those chapters is chapter
800 chapter 800 is the is the chapter
that governs how we permit and and
regulate landfills so it contains a lot
more than just citing criteria and
citing information so we are we actually
already had a listening session on that
chapter early in March uh we had a
public comment period and we received
some comments it was very well attended
we have about 70 participants on a
remote listening session and we also
presented at the beginning of that
listening session some ideas we had for
changes to the chapter and we are
working on those rules now understanding
that this bill is in play right now we
have said and we said they're in that
listening session that um we will be
working on potential of on proposed
amendments to 800 but we will not
address the topic of setbacks until we
know whether whether this bill Pat this
bill is to pass the the rules still
expire in July of 24 so we will adopt
the rules as they're currently are with
any changes that we make the citing
criteria would at least with respect to
surface water would largely remain the
same and then we go ahead and get them
through the rulemaking process get them
passed and make sure that we have a rule
because we let them expire we don't do
anything we don't have a rule anymore so
we don't have rules to govern how we
regulate landfills and that's not an
acceptable situation to us so we will
have rules renewed by July of 24. then
if the bill does pass then we will be
concurrently working on the specific
rulemaking to address surface water
setbacks consistent with the language in
the bill and then we would amend chapter
800 Again by July or by the summer of 25
by that 24 month period if the bill
doesn't pass then we could certainly
look look at potential changes to the
rule in the absence of the bill and
would be at Liberty to do that at any
time we can always propose rulemaking
and go through the rulemaking process
that's been discussed here
but the only thing I'll add is uh the
reason we're supportive of this is we
think this would lead to a better
process for these parts of our rules
um but if if nothing happens we'll just
move it'll be included in the overall
update that we're in the process of
going through
representative Howard
the question is oh thank you madam chair
and thank you for answering my question
um this question is not a reflection of
our trust in your ability to complete
the the requirements of the bill but
doesn't
um the reversion to the old rules in
thank you for the if I understand your
question I think I use the term
open-ended meaning that um for from an
applicant's perspective they could be in
a situation where they would not have
any idea when they were going to get a
decision
so no if if you went to the current
rules Then There It Is Clear when then
they would get a decision
can I have a follow-up sure
um well I guess that's that's my
question is if we were if you had
applicants in the queue who were waiting
for the outcomes of the of the of the
rules that and you did not meet that
two-year rule would would they go would
you could still consider applications
under the old rules
the way I understand the bill if if we
fail to meet that 24-month Target and we
already have an application that's come
before us what the bill let's say we got
an application tomorrow and this bill
were to pass then the direction that the
agency has given under this bill is that
we process that application the way we
always would which means we do a
completeness determination and once it's
determined complete we do a full
technical review we have a public
hearing and then we would be prepared to
render a decision on on the application
under the provisions of this bill we
would hold that decision in advance
until the rules are completed and then
the applicant would be directed to file
supplementary information to their
application to demonstrate how the
application meets the new newly adopted
citing Rule and then we would proceed to
to issuing a decision on the application
if I'm sorry thank you yeah I mean I
think the bottom line is is what makes
describing you know
we understand the the Mandate of this
legislation is to update this Rule and
we would uh we wouldn't to move forward
with an application
um even if it we hit 26 months until the
new rule is in and have it applied to
the application
foreign
representative germana thank you very
much Madam chair
um I want to kind of underscore points
of Representative Haskins made and to
also speak for myself and say it's
frustrating to to have it suggested that
the bill were presented with is it take
it or leave it option that's that's not
how the legislative process is intended
to work and and it's like
with how would the suggestion that the
representative Creighton made which
which makes sense to me which is the
elimination of that part of line seven
which is the reversion to older rules
how does that uh all how would that
alter this bill in a way that would make
it so objectionable that it would no
longer get the governor's signature
supposedly so let me answer the first
I it is it is not in my intent to
put into back anyone in the corner it is
only my intent be to be given the way
the last session ended and how the veto
came into play we were asked by folks to
be as crystal clear as possess as
possible during the process to be clear
about what we thought could eventually
be successful we make it all the way
through so that is all I am trying to do
is to be as honest as possible about
what we have been told about Ken it
works for everyone involved in in this
process that is it you all have to do
your job I respect that and I respect
um you all need to decide what is in the
best interest your constituents in the
state
I'm only here to be as transparent as
possible about what would happen later
on in the process depending on how it
turns out that is my only goal so I have
a question now yeah um well I well there
was representative a second question
about the elimination of the language
okay
um why don't you finish that and then I
have a question
can you
I'm sorry can you repeat that well just
I it eliminated yeah how how eliminating
the part that says we revert to the old
rule if if and and I take you know I
think you guys do a great job and I
assume it will be done in 24 months is
another reason why I don't think we need
to have this statement that it's going
to revert to the old rules because
you'll have it done but how would the
removal of that make this objectionable
to the point where it might not pass I I
think it goes to that issue where there
are a lot of parties with opposing
interests here that are on board with
this bill as it's drafted and one or
more of those may walk if that's changed
that's that's all I can offer
okay thank you very much so my question
is I've seen in the past
especially with Des
um and I know that there there were
rules regarding
another bill that I was working on
having to do with um grease traps in the
ES
and rules are currently being drafted
for that
and the way I was left to understand is
that anybody who was in a situation that
required a grease trap would be
evaluated as if those new rules were
already adopted
why is that not an option here that if
you already know what those new rules
are but you're still going through the
administrative process of putting them
through gel car that you cannot
apply those until those rules are set in
stone
I think that's a legal question I I will
I will offer an answer I I don't know
the specifics of that particular
situation I'm going to guess what the
agency said was rather than put a party
who is going to be regulated by an
expected oncoming rule in a position
where they where they where they weren't
going to be compliant that they would
you know approach their application
review to make sure that not only they
meet the current requirements but they
meet the new requirements that are
anticipated
it's another question entirely to say
whether the agency could legally enforce
that so you know if someone said I want
this grease trap under the current rules
and I'm going to operate it until things
change that way I don't think there'd be
much we could say I mean I think I I'm
pretty confident that there are lots of
folks in the legislature who would be
very upset with Des if we started
enforcing rules that weren't rules yet
and that's what I think you've just
described okay
fair enough and and one other thing I
want to add because as the Director said
if this bill doesn't pass and nothing
passed the decision we'll just
incorporate this in the overall overall
rule making process we are undertaking
we
after last session
we brought we started to talk to the
stakeholders about something how could
we do how could we put a piece of
legislation together that
offered more transparency to the process
we're aware there are some folks who are
concerned about the es and
um you know the relationship we have
with some of the folks we regulate and
and that interaction so this was
actually an attempt to increase the
transparency of the process to have a
third party that would get public
comments about the scope of what that
would look at of bringing in other data
and information to have a more thorough
process than just the traditional
rulemaking process so the reason we
brought this forward was we wanted to
increase the credibility of the process
and we wanted to increase the
transparency and we wanted to increase
the amount of information that could be
gathered and the opportunity folks to
consume that information comment on it
and and have their opinion be heard so
um the irony is the this legislation was
was thought to actually
um uh be a win and and and give
confidence to the folks who have
concerns about
um landfills and how they're cited so uh
just a little more larger background on
on why we're doing this way instead of
not just going right to rulemaking this
adds layers and opportunity for
interaction with the public it adds
layers and
um of information and
um we would hope that that would mean it
would be turn out for a better product
for all of us including in the
department
thank you representative Potenza and
thank you for taking my question so on
page five I don't understand why the
whole line three there if the department
does not that whole thing should be
removed based upon what you just said in
regards with transparency we say on the
page before it has to be done in 24
months we're saying something has to be
done it's great we're all about this it
doesn't make sense that whole paragraph
we shouldn't have a what if it just it I
know there's other people that have
commented on this I just it doesn't need
I don't want to be obtuse but I'm not
sure there's a question I'm happy to
why does it why are you saying that has
to be there
you're saying it on the page before it
has to be completed in 24 months
and also number seven has to happen
first the whole 150 000 that all has to
happen first okay so nothing's going to
rules or jail car until the number
seven's done so I just don't understand
why we're saying it's like you know it's
to me it's like setting it up to fail I
just feel as if we're saying it has to
be done in 24 months on you know June
30th 2023 we're gonna
do the you know take in the rfps for the
150 000.
I don't understand why we can't remove
that tell me why we can't remove that I
think it goes to this this I think it's
the same answer that I gave
representative germano I think it's that
that there are parties who won't support
uh yeah sure but what parties
you know the other gentleman said you
know he talked about his stakeholders
who who were these parties
who are these stakeholders I'd like to
know
as well as Des is to bring forward what
we think
answer questions about what we think
would work best for
um our process
and
and so we we contributed to the process
from the perspective of Des
as I said at the end of the last session
we were criticized for not being more
transparent about what we thought could
and couldn't be successfully make it all
the way through the process so
I am all and this isn't Mike this is all
I am all I was here to do today was to
let folks know that
version of this bill that's in front
has the support needed to make it all
the way through the process this is
amended
it'll be up to it'll be up to the Senate
whether they want to pass the other
version and it'll be up to the governor
whatever version gets to his desk if
he's going to sign it or not I was
simply saying
this is a version of the bill and a
process that DS can support we're
publicly saying we can support that and
we're probably saying we believe it
would have the broad-based support it
would need it to be able to come to law
if you all
feel that something else is needs to
happen to the bill
the process will continue we'll make our
comments on the updated version of the
bill and we'll see how the process plays
representative Dusty
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh representative
pretenza um kind of hit on my question
but we know that our stakeholders are
our constituents as as legislators and
they want clean water okay uh you have
used the word stakeholder a number of
times and in you know
um uh for transparency reasons
it's is it possible for you to talk
about who your stakeholders are because
from what I see there's only one
stakeholder that has any power at all
and that's the governor so if there are
stakeholders in this process there must
be other people that are applying
pressure so it'd be really nice to know
who they are yeah I mean I was nominated
by the governor so I mean he's my boss
so uh so that has a part of it of course
she's one of my stakeholders in one of
the department stakeholders is the chief
executive officer of the state
government
um and uh we work together on
legislation of uh we get his advice on
the policy he'd like to see come out of
legislation and he gets Our advice on
the technical impacts and
um and our thoughts on the policy so we
work with the governor to make sure
we're moving forward with policy that is
going to work for the executive branch
but our stakeholders include include the
listing legislature the executive
Council the residents of the state the
businesses of the state the uh the
communities we regulate
um while we are The Regulators we find
it that having a an approach of
cooperation and communication
um leads to better outcomes for all
involved
um so we work for the entire State of
New Hampshire it's residents it's
businesses and we work with all the
elected officials of the state
government our sister agencies and the
other state employees so everyone is our
stakeholder
um and
um yes the the the again
my only goal is
is you know it's it's you know it's it's
a lose-lose situation last time we
weren't as clear about what we what
could pass and what could ultimately
make it through the process and what we
supported so
um so all we are trying to do is say
be more clear about that and that's to
say we think this piece I am confident
this piece of legislation is something
the department can support and voice
their support on and it is something
that I believe has a balance that can
make it all the way through the process
if if it changes then the process will
continue to work itself out and we're
just one we're just one part of that and
one voice in all of that and
um will continue to be as transparent as
possible about what we think will lead
to a good rulemaking process and what
won't
okay representative Bixby yeah I'd like
to shift things a little bit um
there was a question earlier about uh
the uh conflicts of interest and how
those are dealt with and I'm was
wondering uh is there something that is
currently in department rules or in the
statutes that govern the department that
lay out how conflicts of interest are
assessed and dealt with so this is uh
this is uh what I think I can commit to
we will work with the Attorney General's
office and their they you know you know
they we have template language for rfps
and then we have the ability to add in
we will work with the Attorney General's
office on Crafting conflict of interest
language that'll go into the RFP
as we stated earlier that RFP is going
to have public comment if the language
isn't sufficient we will take all the
comments related to that and amend
appropriately as long as we get approval
from the Attorney General's office that
it's language we can legally move
forward with
thank you
what other points along the way uh is
public interest public comment rather
accepted and dealt with so official
public comment periods there will be one
when we have a a draft ready of the RFP
that we will we will put out for public
comment period
um and then the next time for official
public comment period will be during the
rulemaking rule making process there is
built into it a public comment period
that being said again back to the who do
we work for we take input every day you
know you know as if along the way uh
folks have concerns about how things are
progressing we are open our door is
always open uh and we will work with
anyone to
um to ensure that and address any
concerns they have and shift something
if the points they make
um is going to lead to a better process
so you've identified two points there's
two officials within this there would be
there'd be two official public comment
periods there'd be one when the RFP
draft is ready and we get public comment
period on that and then during the
rulemaking process there's an official
public comment period as part of that
process
thank you I just wanted to make sure I
was reading that Bill Wright myself so
if you want to miss any other any any
other point of public comment any other
questions uh representative Haskins
director wimps at so my question now is
what point along the process would the
legislature be apprised of where you are
um well as has been discussed during the
rulemaking process The Joint legislative
committee and administrative rules is a
key role in that when we file our
initial proposal that's filed with the
office of legislative services and
shared with the members of the committee
um the office often gives us input very
early on to the initial proposal we work
with them to make sure we get things
right and then we go to public hearing
and then our own public hearing for the
rules and then following that as we get
ready to file a final proposal that
final proposal gets reviewed by OLS in
the in the committee and then there's a
hearing before the committee so we get
that's the key sort of built-in times
when we get
information or when we get input from
the legislature certainly this will be a
completely public process the RP will be
out for public comment we'll take
comments on that we'll do that and then
we'll when that contractor is selected
and they're doing their work we will get
a final report there's no built-in
public comment period final following
the final report issuance and that is
largely because we need to be getting
our work underway at that time in or at
least our will already be underway but
we'll need to be looking at the content
of that final report to see how it
should inform our rulemaking but it'll
be a public document as soon as it's
released to us and at that point
um the public would certainly be at
Liberty to share any thoughts they have
about the report and we would certainly
be in a position to consider those as we
as we draft our continue drafting the
rules
so I know you directed the question to
uh director but I'll make this offer on
a number of other issues and uh projects
and uh follow up on legislation
um we do monthly update calls
um Etc
um if it was of interest
um we would be happy to make part of
this process a monthly update call to
the legislators who are interested in
this and any other stakeholder who's
interested in this so we could have a a
consistent regular update about the
progress we're making
um especially since the senator Waters
pointed out part of of what is built in
all this is there is another session and
if there were concerns they could be
addressed then so
um uh we are we again our goal is for
everyone to feel they had every
opportunity to have their voice heard as
part of whatever process we come up with
and I I am happy to to offer on behalf
of the Department a willingness to do
you know a monthly call update with the
legislature legislators who are
interested in it to update on the
process progress we're making
um and take feedback from their
perspective
representative Murray
I we're a public body and so we're we we
uh we are what we do is is open to all
members of the public so
um if if you all wanted a a specific one
for you all that's fine
um if other legislators asked us to do
um you know to do an update call as well
other stakeholders we'd be happy to do
that we with with
highly sensitive uh projects and issues
where there's a lot of public interest
we do all we can to make ourselves
available as possible
um so folks know what is happening and
the progress that is being made so happy
to make it however works for for the
requester
germana uh thank you very much Madam
chair and director room set following
the public uh input uh portion of the
the process will there be a time when
the department will respond to as I
think is often the case with Federal
kind of public uh input sessions you'll
respond to some of the Public's like how
is the public going to know that you
have listened to them because there's a
question about stakeholders is one thing
to to hear what the public has to say
it's another thing to demonstrate that
you've heard what they have to say and
that it is in fact informing your
process so is there a public an
opportunity to to let the public know
you've heard them sure so I I don't
think that the the bill is drafted
requires specifically that a response to
public comments be issued and that's
actually not it's required for some of
our permitting programs and not for
others we in in our Solid Waste
permitting program those who are
familiar with our Solid Waste permit
decisions will know that we actually
issue a pretty detailed and lengthy
response to public comments I'm not sure
we would propose to do that here just
because it takes a lot of work to do
that and we want to be focusing our
attention on reviewing those comments
appropriately incorporating them into
the final RFP and getting the RFP out
the door so that the study begins
thank you director thank you madam chair
any other questions for
director wimsat nope
thank you and um thank you
appreciate your your time
um representative Wendy Thomas town of
Merrimack
good afternoon I'm representative Wendy
Thomas I represent the town of Merrimack
um
so I'm here to talk about Senate Bill 61
which is a good bill but it it needs a
few tweaks and I'm going to start off
with some advice that my dad gave me
when I signed my first contract he said
make sure or he said never take anyone's
word that things will just excuse me
that things will just happen be sure to
have it in writing
uh I'm going to tell you about why we
need to strengthen guard rails in this
bill when it comes to the health of New
Hampshire residents and our environment
specifically as it applies to pfas
consider this a cautionary tale if we
get this bill wrong
as you know pfas is called a forever
chemical and the reason it's called a
forever chemical is it does not break
down pfas is found in Burger wrappers
pizza boxes dental floss discarded
clothing old pots and pans
exactly what you find in a landfill
you will hear from others about why some
changes to this bill are needed and
they're so important
but I'm going to start with my story in
2016 I heard about pfas in our town we
had a corporate a commercial industry in
our town that was contaminating our
water
initially the state Des told us that
only the residents that were within a
half mile of this Corporation needed to
be concerned about their water
after doing a little bit of testing they
said are bad it's really the people that
live within a mile of this corporation
that need to be concerned
I live three miles from sancobain I had
our private well tested and it tested so
high we had to shut down our well
immediately
I have six children they had been
drinking contaminated water their entire
lives
we put in a whole house filtration
system with reverse osmosis
at a cost of about five thousand dollars
and it costs five hundred dollars a year
to maintain the filters for this system
all of the water that we currently drink
comes and cook with comes from bottled
water we do not use the water from our
house
in 2021 we had our well tested again and
the numbers were even higher than they
were in 2016.
all six of my children have medical
conditions that are associated with pfas
kids well they're adults young adults
they have cardiac issues they have
autoimmune issues they have high
cholesterol issues they have skin rashes
my husband had a quadruple bypass in
2019 at age
55. that's associated with pfas
I recently put down my fourth small dog
due to cancer
my doctors believe that my cancer is
from quote environmental toxins because
there is no code for pfas poisoning
cincobain has said that they will hook
our house up to public water
they've given us a time frame of seven
to nine years
we cannot downsize our house who's going
to buy a house that has no water
I've told all of my kids to move away
from Merrimack
pfas in our water has cost us a lot of
money aggravation and heartache and now
there appears to be no end in sight as
it continues to this day
we can't stop it we are getting no help
so listen to the proposed changes to
this bill we have a chance to get this
right and protect peoples and animals
Health this is literally a matter of
life and death
because once this pfest once this pfas
toothpaste is out of the tube we're
never going to put it back in
okay thank you any questions from the
committee
thank you for your testimony
I call Bob Grillo from I believe it's
CMA Engineers from Portsmouth
foreign
g-r-i-l-l-o there you go thank you okay
um thanks for the opportunity to give my
comments to the committee on SB 61 my
testimonial argue in favor passage of
the bill my name is Bob Grillo I'm a
principal at CMA Engineers a civil and
environmental engineering company
headquartered in Portsmouth I practice
landfill Engineering in New Hampshire
continuously since 1986 starting with
the first double-line landfill in the
state I'm a licensed professional
engineer and geologist in New Hampshire
so with this background I offer the
following comments some of this has been
covered earlier in great detail so I
will make this brief
sb61 has Provisions for hiring
consultant to assess
the landfill the landfill surface to
water setback rules and Supply
recommendations for any needed
enhancement of these setback rules the
consultant solicitation should require
interested firms to be qualified in a
broad range of fields those including
Solid Waste engineering hydrogeology
environmental assessment radiation and
risk management
regarding the conflicts of interest I I
support what the director and his
assistant said on that and I'm confident
that they can make a selection that'll
satisfy everyone's concerns there
um
also as stated by the director sb61
requires public involvement in the
solicitation of the consultant as well
as in the rulemaking that would follow
the completion of the consultant's work
this public transparent process should
strengthen the resulting rules and the
public confidence in them SB 61 supports
and enhances the nhges rulemaking
process one that includes The Regulators
the public and business and
environmental stakeholders SB 61
significantly improves in my opinion the
earlier legislation that prescribed
simplified and unscientific methods in
the bill itself and affects
short-circuiting this rulemaking process
which I think is important Uh current
New Hampshire Solid Waste rules require
landfills to be built with a secondary
liner and leaked leachate detection
system below the primary liner
um
so so this system supplies a redundant
barrier to flow and the flow and leakage
and leachate collection and provides a
means to continuously check the
performance of the primary liner if it's
leaking it'll show up and it's measured
daily so the existing New Hampshire
regulatory program of robust groundwater
monitoring combined with near continuous
monitoring of the primary line
containment system has performed
exceedingly well over the last 36 years
I'm not aware of one double Line
Landfill that has leaked and needed
groundwater remediation over this entire
36-year period when these landfills have
been in service in the state with that
said I understand there's still concerns
and there's still risk possibly
sp-61 contemplates nhdes considering
added measures or engineering controls
to enhance these protections and add
redundancy to the landfill containment
systems these measures should address
real or perceived risk on a
site-specific basis and a support
acceptance of the you know and
acceptance of any reduced travel times
as a result I support these provisions
of SB 61. thank you for your
consideration
and uh Mr Grillo would you be able to
submit your testimony uh written
testimony yes um I have 10 copies I
understand you need more yeah just for
the clerk did you send it to us by email
as well yes you all got it by email okay
any questions for Mr Grillo oh I'm sorry
I'm representative Murray
yep yeah
yeah thank you Mr Grillo for taking my
question so I did just want to speak
really quickly about double liner
systems and if you could clarify
um they are not always
plastic double liners correct sometimes
it is one-liners plastic and one liner
maybe clay in New Hampshire the rules
require two plastic liners and there is
a soil component beneath the lower one
yes
any other questions
committee representative Haskins thank
you madam chair Mr Grillo are you aware
of double liners leaking yes
so you know at times we hear a double
liner is state of the art do you think
it's state of the art I I do and and if
I could explain in just a minute
um so you have a lining system on top
and you you measure any liquid that gets
through that lining system to the second
liner it's usually a very small amount
most of the time it's clean water that
gets in from the edges but nonetheless
there is a little bit of water there
then you have the second system
underneath it which has to deal with
much much less water and you can
actually calculate based on what kind of
holes you had in the first liner what is
in the second liner calculate what goes
through and it's such a small amount yes
I mean no one's perfect no materials are
perfect this thing was made by man but
the amount of leakage is so small
through that second liner that is
immeasurable and that's been the case
over these last 30 something years that
the monitoring Wheels do not pick up any
of the contamination from the landfill
in the groundwater
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none I would call Representative
Walter Stapleton
foreign
good afternoon my name is representative
Walt Stapleton
from Sullivan County District Six the
towns of Claremont and Croydon
I'm here in support of SB 61 but with
we've come a long way from
1454 and almost got there with
56. I was quite in favor of
The Five-Year time in travel formula
but of course that was telling the
professionals what specific method to
use
in current and developing science
so while I was disappointed we don't see
the time and travel within
this bill the reference to other states
use current technology and science
we've turned the rock over and it should
be evident what's out there from the
Department's ability to investigate
and I'm happy that with all the efforts
over these couple of terms here
that the antique Antiquated method of
feet distance is uh
recognizes tantamount to driving a Model
T down I-93
we don't want to be doing that anymore
the problems
that I see
um
three of them
there's no mention of
landfill sites over or near aquifers as
there was in the amendment to HB 56.
well maybe we have to address that at
some other point or if there's going to
be an amendment
perhaps we might include mention of that
as a
criteria to look at as well as the surf
perennial surface waters
the second item
the bill is absent conflicts of interest
with regard to site geology assessment
contractors
but I'm satisfied that what the
department has said relative to
including that within the RFP and
working with the AG
Ates
a sensitivity to that concern
but at least if there's going to be an
amendment perhaps just a mention that
adequate
conflicts of interest concerns would be
addressed
but the Big Kahuna is the page five
Roman 3
if the department does not adopt new
rules within 24 months
of the effective date of this act
etc etc
we go back to square one
and the Model T on I-93
and we can't be doing that
my concerns are with some of the outline
process of times
of which there are quite a few in there
30 days of the ACT
to post the RFP draft
30 days after that for public comment
um
there's something missing in here
the bill is missing an award date or at
least the number of days
after submission deadline
for the Department to respond
so that there's no so that there's a
check against erosion of time available
for the Department to adopt and
incorporate
the little rules in time to avoid that
reversion to existing standards
again missing the award date or a number
of days in that linear process to make
the award
serious erosion of time could occur for
essentially a slow process for staff
problems other emergencies whatever
could be an unfortunate Escape escape
hatch
for missing this opportunity
so instead there should
really be at Roman 3 a mandate to
complete the work
even with the delay and that would
comprehend
extension provisions
like six months for apps in process to
be held in advance for unforeseen
um
we can't just
dump it off the cliff
and I think that's what Romans Section 3
does
and hopefully that would be the most
important item included in an amendment
which I hope the committee will
incorporate into this very fine bill
which otherwise is very comprehensive
satisfactory well thought well
constructed
but we have to plug the holes
and that concludes my opinion on this
uh representative Stapleton thank you do
you have written testimony to him to the
clerk no I don't that's just rough notes
off the top of my head okay thank you
okay
any questions for representative
Stapleton
nope seeing none no no no okay seeing
none thank you and I now call Wayne
Morrison
good afternoon good afternoon to
environment and agriculture
thank you
um
let me start by saying I heard a lot of
interesting things I heard I heard some
very good things I just start by going
back to what Senator Waters said that
there is a growing desire to get
um I want to amplify that a thousand
percent we need to get something done
um for the record my name is Wayne
Morrison and I am president of a
Grassroots organization called North
Country Alliance for balance change
we have been in front of this committee
and and the your counterparts in the
Senate over the last four or five years
bringing house bills 177.
uh House Bill 1454 house bill 56.
I want you to know I've spent the first
six years of my retirement working on
Solid Waste something that I never
thought in a million years I would be
doing
I want to support
I think the concepts in this
legislations are ones we can agree with
at least in principle
however
in good faith and after working these
issues for a good length of time
there are some things in this bill that
I think and we have been discussing but
that need to be addressed
the intentions of the stakeholders you
know there are a lot of stakeholders in
this
I don't understand how it could possibly
be that by somehow improving this bill
that it would get destroyed
I don't know what's in the governor's
head I don't know why he chose to veto
House Bill 1454 it was good legislation
and so is House Bill 56 but we are where
we are and the question is what are we
We Have Heard on multiple occasions from
from Des
through their testimony that they need
additional technical knowledge to feel
comfortable in making a change to the
I think we should give Des whatever they
need
to reach a good conclusion and change a
32 year old
inadequate unsafe
unhelpful dangerous
200 foot setback that not only doesn't
make sense to me but I think if you
lined up 95 percent of the population of
this state and you said 200 feet is
barely out the door do you think that's
enough space between a lake a river of
the Atlantic Ocean and a landfill
I think you'd get a resounding
no way that's insane we need to fix it
I am I spent my career in technology I
believe in technology I'm a business
person my life has been enriched by
working for corporations I am by no
means against business
but I live in New Hampshire because
clean air clean water Open Spaces I love
this state
as it turns out my family owns property
on Forest Lake in Whitefield New
Hampshire
I have I wish Casella no ill will but
they have picked a terrible sight
to plan a mega landfill near the amnusic
River Forest Lake Forest Lake State Park
and a recreation area
all the technology in the world is great
but you as a legislative body as you
think about policy you should assume
that things are going to fail
you should assume double liners triple
liners quadruple liners monitoring Wells
all of that stuff we should do all of it
but the point of a setback is when the
hits the fan and something goes
wrong that we have enough time to
intercept it before a river gets
polluted and before drinking water gets
polluted and there's no remediation for
that you heard from Wendy Thomas
the awful story that she had to tell you
I don't understand why it's taken this
long this is one slice one small piece
of a complicated
system of solid waste in the state that
needs to be fixed we have a lot of
issues to deal with I have great respect
for Des they have a very difficult job
but as a member of the public as
somebody that has been fighting
to make solid waste reform and change
I'm appalled that it's five years into
the process and we are still now it's
going to be two more
if we if we pass this bill
and I'm telling you we don't need this
is not rocket science
yes we should we should go off and we
should get I'm all in favor of of a lot
of this bill we should go off and get
the best Minds we should Benchmark what
the best states are doing
but we got to get moving
all I ask from you as you as you
contemplate this bill
I think you should think about conflict
of interest in this business is is a
real issue New Hampshire is a small
state
my little Grassroots organization went
off to try and hire a solid waste
engineer
and I can tell you
months into the process every one of
those people is tied to the solid waste
industry in this state they have
conflicts of interest
we need to find competent people
but that is not an easy task and I want
to believe in this process I don't think
anyone's going into this process not
trying to do the right thing but
it is very important that we find
somebody that's independent that is
going to actually give us the kind of
data and the whatever that report tends
ends up being
we want that to be real stuff we don't
want window dressing we want real action
if we're going to spend 150 000 in this
state we want to spend it wisely we want
to get our money's worth and we want to
get on with a real action here to get
I would also I would also remind the
committee
that there's a couple of things that are
just true
there are currently no applications for
a new landfill development in front of
Des
and any applicant that does come forward
knows what the what's been transpiring
for the last five years and that there's
changes coming in this and the the
regulations are going to change
I'm sympathetic to business and I want
us to do the right thing
but I am even equally sympathetic to the
public who is asking for environmental
health and safety protection
every day I read about toxic stuff
that's in landfills in that leachate
and if you aren't discomforted by the
fact that the 200-foot set book 30 years
ago we didn't know well today we know a
lot more and we know it is more and more
and more dangerous
the second thing I would ask you to
contemplate
is that the Department of Environmental
Services published a biennial report
back in November
and in it it says we don't have any
capacity issue
we don't need a new landfill tomorrow
we may need one 10 years from now
I question if we even need it then but
we have plenty of time to get this right
and if we're going to invest if we're
going to if we're going to allow if
we're going to permit another landfill
that's going to last a hundred years or
200 years
please don't let a month or two get in
the way of doing the right thing on this
bill
the people of this state deserve
much better than what we've been living
with
and I believe
that we are fortunate
that our health and safety and the leaks
and the problems that we hear all over
the country in some of these places we
are not better off because of our
regulation we we are better off in spite
of our regulation I think we've been
lucky
don't let a disaster happen when you
know that it we can do better than this
the people of New Hampshire deserve more
than what we're giving them and the time
to act is now and I don't know what the
governor is going to do
but you should do the right thing and as
you did with 1454 if the governor makes
the wrong decision you have the power to
override it
so I ask you to stand up and do the
right thing for the people of New
thank you any questions
from the committee nope
thank you very much
uh I'd like to get on we we are you know
going when we've got a lot of pink cards
here
um I would like to call Nora Bosworth to
okay it's passing around
hello again
good afternoon chairman Aaron and
honorable committee members
you're going to hear a lot of similar
points the ones that were just made but
they were good ones
I'm the zero way staff attorney for
Northern New England for the
conservation law foundation and clf
supports
sb61 provided that it is amended in a
few important and modest ways
we believe that with the Amendments I'm
going to speak to this bill could be a
huge step forward for the state's
protection of its Waters and residents
and site-specific setbacks are necessary
because all landfill liner systems have
limited lifespans and can eventually
leak some slowly over time and others
shortly after installation
Des has admitted that landfill liner
systems have finite lifespans
and waste in conventional subtitle D
landfills remain hazardous and otherwise
harmful to groundwater quality for as
long as they remain buried and leachable
components persist which is centuries to
Millennia into the future far beyond the
36 years that we can look to now
so for all these reasons it is essential
that New Hampshire adopts stronger
protections to prevent contamination of
surface waters
and I just want to add since we've been
talking a lot about what we're still
discovering uh this year alone the EPA
studied 200 landfills across the country
and tested the leachate for pfas and
found pfas in 95 percent of the leachate
of the 200 landfills across the country
so this legislation would be far more
effective if it specified that the
contractor hired to assess the setback
regulations must be independent and
appropriately qualified
the independent third party should not
be affiliated with any past or current
projects on behalf of a current landfill
owner or operator
nor have a past current or intended
future client relationship with any
landfill owner or operator this is a
basic conflict of interest provision and
the language is in there to guide this
amendment
Additionally the contractor should be a
qualified hydrogeologist with
demonstrated capability to assess and
determine appropriate setback
requirements for landfills as well as
have significant experience in
and as many of us have been touching on
via bands on new landfill permit
applications should last until the new
site-specific regulations are adopted
period
the 200-foot setback is an inadequate
inadequate protection and thus we are
here and this bill requires the adoption
of new site-specific regulations and it
is irresponsible
to allow the issuance of a landfill
permit under outdated rules simply
because the agency completes their Duty
potentially in more months than
anticipated
Des is already Limited in their timeline
by the months required to hire a
contractor and the 150 days allowed for
that contractor to finalize the
recommendations that Des has to then
take into account when they propose new
regulations so it's not a full 24 months
by any means
the events on the granting of new
landfill permits should last until the
new regulations the better protections
are adopted even if such adoption
the abandons does not work for everyone
despite what we've heard it does not
work for residents who live near
landfills or future landfills and clf
urges the committee to amend SB 61 as
discussed above
and then to vote as amended that it
ought to pass
thank you so much for your time
thank you Ms Bosworth any questions from
the committee
seeing none thank you again and oh I'm
sorry represent Bixby I didn't see your
hand yeah well it was a little slow in
raising it I just wanted to make sure
that the uh your suggestions are all
clearly laid out in the uh written
testimonials written testimony you gave
us in terms of if we wanted to look at
those for language they certainly are
good afternoon uh committee and chairman
and the chairwoman excuse me this is my
first time ever testifying in front of a
committee or in any particular
um issue in front of the state and I'm
I'm very pleased to be in front of you
here a little bit nervous so just bear
with me as I I talk a little bit here
um I my name is Michael Wright I'm from
Littleton New Hampshire I was born and
raised in Littleton and I've lived in uh
the three corners of the state I guess
up in the North Country down in the
Seacoast as well as around Keene and I
can tell you I love this state and
there's a lot to love about it and this
is a reason why it's a real drop for
many people that visit the state as well
as they want to move here and one of the
primary things is to the beauty of our
our state in the waters that we have and
so I I'm very pleased to be able to come
in front of you and talk about how I
feel about making sure that we continue
to have clean water in front of the
state I got to tell you I'm a little bit
fascinated by the whole process today
somewhat gobsmacked when I hear that
maybe it's not binary it's a binary
decision on SB 61 it's either take it or
lead it type of proposition that's not
how I thought the legislative sausage
was actually created I thought it was
through
discussion and and from argument
arguments if you want to call it that
but just the Liberation about what's
best for the actual policies that you
may be working upon
I I wanted to take a moment here and
read the testimony from Adam Fink I
think that you may know of him he's uh
Dr Adam pink he's a an environmental uh
scientist and he's currently the
clinical uh professor of Environmental
Health Services over at the University
of Michigan
so um this won't take I'm not going to
read his entire submitted
testimony here and I'll abbreviate it a
little bit but let me let me go through
it
over the last two years the house agreed
with the experts who testified that New
Hampshire is decades behind the rules of
other states and the guidance of the U.S
EPA and that the state should require a
five-year time of travel setback between
new landfills and surface waters
using the maximum measured value of
site-specific pollutant velocity this
formula is actually weaker than the
sixth year of the 12-year setbacks in
other states that have a thriving
landfill Industries some of which
actually simply ban landfills and sandy
soil like the one proposed up in Dalton
this year the DS and the Senate have
publicly admitted what the experts have
always known the one size fits all 200
foot setback is an embarrassment and a
danger to our citizens
uh unwittingly though excuse me uh the
Senate apparently with SB 61 apparently
does not appreciate the difference
between science and policy between
undeniable facts and legitimate disputes
over values
despite my 35 years experience
conducting pioneering research and
environmental sciences and
evidence-based regulations for federal
state and city in environmental agencies
I that is a Dr pink should not be
empowered to make value-laden policies
for the State of New Hampshire
but neither should any of the other
unelected scientists be given this power
making policy is the job of the
legislature a buck that should not be
passed to someone unaccountable perhaps
untrained in certain uh and certainly
biased
the fallacy at the heart of SB 61 is its
false claim that there is still science
that a consultant must figure out
I can assure you that despite what
you'll hear today which we have here
today from vested interests the science
is settled
much indeed is unsettled but that is all
policy and values
so here's an analogy to the Trap that
the Senate has fallen into imagine the
legislature had never set a speed for
the State Highway of course there will
be a legitimate argue over whether the
limit should be 40 60 or 100 miles per
hour and there'll be a controversy over
whether someone should be pulled over
for speeding far above the limit for a
minute or so or whether the police
should have to follow him for an hour
and only penalize him if the long run
average speed is above the posted limit
but there isn't any doubt that we know
how to measure the speed of a car we
have speedometers and radar guns for
this just as we have had very accurate
tests for groundwater velocity for many
years I heard testimony today that
that that's something the state doesn't
know anything about I mean it's science
so I respectfully defy any of the
Consultants supporting that sb61 as is
to identify one single issue that
requires more research here and Dr pink
has submitted a one-page chart that
explains what could possibly be the
major value judgments that a consultant
report will make
so the Senate wants to Outsource the
policy to a consultant rather than to
make the hard choices about how to be
protected this is especially
disappointing because HB 56 had already
made that hard choice and in a common
sense way on the successes of the states
and on the science but it's even worse
than this you all know precisely what
the answer would be if you awarded a
speed limit contract to a consultant out
of Ferrari we've studied the issue and
we think everyone should be able to
derive 120 miles per hour on the road
anytime after all all studies show that
someone once did that and didn't yet
kill anyone
I and others have offered a small set of
technical changes to sb61 it can be
improved to make a somewhat less of a
giveaway to the regulated industry it
would still Outsource policy policy
authority to one or more Consultants but
at least it would balance uh balance
this mistake with meaningful expert
review and respectable public input with
reason Des responses to it
but even with these changes it would be
a huge concession for the house to
accept the premise of sb61 that a
consultant actually should make the
environmental policy for the state
so there is one simple way to change one
aspect of SB 661 to satisfy the
perceived need for more study without
leaving the state at the mercy of one
unelected person's preferences the
legislature should direct the consultant
to make the recommendation directly to
the elected officials and you would then
instruct Des how to change its dangerous
rules this would compromise between the
legislative branch to finish the job now
as HB 56 would have done and never doing
the job as SB 61 in its present form
would do
this way the legislature can at least
have opened the possibility of creating
a balanced precautionary setback rule
that will achieve its crucial and very
long overdue goal to steer applicants
away from the tiny minority of the worst
most obviously ruinous places where pfas
Laden trash need never and should never
I really can't take many questions for
just a clarification on the name is that
is that Dr Adam Finkel f-i-n-c-k my
apologies and I know he's watching
online he could make it here today
because he had some medical appointments
and uh I'll be hearing from him because
it's actually Adam Finkel okay thank you
yeah thank you
any further questions thank you for your
time thank you
good afternoon
good afternoon Madam chair and committee
members uh thank you for this
opportunity to provide testimony and
comments to uh sb61 my testimonies in
support of SB 61 I've provided written
comments of my own as well as a
colleague Eric steinhauser and we will
be emailing the comments to the
committee as well
my name is Tim White I'm a vice
president at Sanborn head and Associates
of multi-disciplinary engineering and
geosciences consulting firm
headquartered in Bedford we currently
serve private and public clients several
of New Hampshire's lined in unlined
landfills
our environmental and Engineering
clients also include nhdes and Dot
I'm a hydrogeologist at San Juan hand
and I've worked in the field of geology
for over 21 years I'm a licensed
professional geologist in New Hampshire
as well as five other states
I want to Briefly summarize two key
points in support of sb61 the first
sp-61 uses science and requires
site-specific approach for determining
landfill setbacks to Perennial surface
water and secondly sb61 proposes that
Des engage a qualified contractor to
study the setback rules and make
recommendations regarding the first
point the science
sp61 requires calculation of
Representative groundwater travel times
using site-specific information it does
not require a rely on a
one-size-fits-all approach which would
not be representative to conditions at
most sites additionally sb61 includes
options for specific engineering
improvements that provide enhanced
protection for human health in the
environment
these measures provide secondary and in
some cases tertiary protections that are
above and beyond the current state and
federal regulations
together these important considerations
reflect Advantage advances in solid
waste engineering and design
technologies that offer protection by
either decreasing the likelihood a
release would occur reducing the impact
a potential release may have
or increasing the ability to detect and
respond to the release
regarding my second point the study by
qualified Professionals in my opinion
the best firm for the study will have
several professionals with extensive
multi-state Solid Waste landfill design
permitting construction operation and
monitoring experience
although the selected contractors may be
professionally licensed in New Hampshire
this should not be an absolute
requirement
rather the professionals working on the
study should have engineering and
hydrogeologic expertise and credentials
that are materially equivalent to what
is required for landfill licensure in
New Hampshire
there's been a lot of concern expressed
today about uh concerns about interest
and lack of interest and transparency in
our industry and I just want to say
those negative assertions simply aren't
based on fact
protection of Public Health in the
environment is at the very core of what
we do as environmental professionals and
Engineers every day we are bound by
rules and regulations no one's above law
as part of our professional licensure we
also are bound by a code of strict code
of ethics to avoid the types of
conflicts of interest that were
expressed today
I'm confident that Des has the ability
to vet these real and perceived
conflicts of interest as part of the com
the Contracting process
I think though that these tactics ignore
that the assessment that is proposed in
sv61 to study the setback by qualified
professionals is scientifically sound
and a responsible approach that makes
sense for New Hampshire and it specifies
a regional time frame and framework for
completion I urge this committee to move
forward with SB 61 I'm confident Des
will be able to engage a highly
qualified professional firm independent
to do their work and complete the study
and I'm looking forward to reviewing the
results
and I have any questions if the
community have would be happy to answer
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Howard
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um are you current is Sanborn head
currently under contract with the state
uh chamberhead does have a contract with
the ES4 environmental work at many of
the site Superfund sites and other
Brownfield sites that the state manages
thank you
representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair
um thank you for taking my question uh I
guess your testimony and the testimony
of previous engineering firms has raised
a question for me because it's my
understanding I mean I I guess I've
heard people say that this lays out good
scientific information
and am I wrong all it does is talk about
going out for an RFP and suggests that
whoever wins this contract look at some
of these things but nothing in this is
science and nothing in this uh has to be
in the final report am I wrong or is
that what this bill is all about thank
you for your question representative if
I read this bill uh this is uh in
Section 3 a on page two the what the
proposed language there is offers more
specifics than are in the current
regulations about how the travel time in
groundwater is calculated
um specifically lines 26 through 32. I
think that's the additional specifics
that are being
um being added in this bill
follow-up but yeah aren't these just
suggested recommendations I mean I don't
I don't see any science I mean I don't
see any qualitative information here
that you know
um I mean for example in HB 56 there was
qualitative data you know about you know
how far uh yeah I mean how far water
should travel and remedies that we
should take
I just see this as suggestions I mean so
I'm not sure where I see the science in
here so
um to answer your follow-up question
representative I believe the how the
bill is written is it takes those
sections uh the language in three and as
part of the study one of the outcomes is
recommendations based on the outcome of
and it includes recommendations of any
other factors that the consultant team
is necessary for protection of perennial
surface water X I believe there's more
specifics that will be coming out of
any other questions representative
germana
thank you madam chair and thank you for
for taking my question I'm hoping you
can answer a question that I've had
since we heard testimony on on HB 56
regarding the use of this term one size
fits all and and also the idea of
something being site-specific so I'm
certainly not a fan of our current 30
year old standard of 200 feet I think
travel time is is how we should be
measuring these things but this is my my
question even if taking that 200 foot
setback
that's a minimum right and and you
conduct a series of tests right to
determine what the specific geology is
at that site
and then there is a determination of how
far the setback should be
is that that is that not
site-specific right because with that
minimum or if we take a five-year
setback the time travel time that we
discussed in in HP 56
that is a particular standard but you're
always doing specific geological testing
at the site so whatever the actual
setback is whether that's 200 feet or a
thousand feet or two miles it still
site-specific regardless of that
standard and the real and I'm hoping you
can clarify this for me I'm thinking
about if I go to buy a pair of pants
right pants are determined the size is
determined by waste and inseam that
doesn't make all pants one size fits all
right it's you have a set of criteria
and then it's specific to the individual
so if you could I would appreciate if
you could clarify for me this this this
language around one size fits all
because as long as you're doing the
specific testing
it is site specific is it not uh sure
thank you for your question
representative I think
um the the one size fits all I'm that
I'm referring to the the 200 foot
setback under the current regs would not
be allowed if Des determined that that
is not protective to surface water
that's how the current regulations read
so no one could put put a landfill at
200 feet right now if if it were not
protective what I'm referring to
specifically with a one-size-fits all is
the the other legislation that I've
reviewed indicates that a certain
maximum values from a site for
permeability for instance must be used
and that is not specific that would not
fall into our site specific it would not
be represented to a vast majority of
that site potentially and so I juxtapose
that that value that is maybe measured
at one point in one location it may not
be represented for a bulk of the the
site and in particularly the area down
gradient from the landfill where it
really matters
in a quick follow-up if I may sure
random charges and I guess I I think it
is a difference in usage in that case
that you just provided right in in terms
of thinking about maximum velocity for
example the site specif specific element
is still the geological
you know strata right I mean that so
you're right there's a there's a maximum
and that would be applied across uh all
sites that are tested but then the
site-specific element is it not is what
you find when you drill down correct so
under the under the current regulations
I I do not believe I don't mean to speak
for DS I do not believe they would look
to use a maximum as being representative
as a site
um under the current the citing rules
now and that's what the proposed
legislation did was it selected a
maximum value and that I'm saying it
would not be representative of
potentially vast majorities of portions
of that site and there's a danger in
that because I don't think you're you're
getting a representative read on what
the the travel time of groundwater might
be if you were to take that maximum
value
thank you for taking my question thank
you madam chair any other questions from
the committee see yes uh representative
Haskins thank you madam chair
um so I guess I understand that there's
an engineering piece that goes into it
certainly but would you agree that part
of our job is a health risk assessment
that that's as critical as the
engineering that goes into putting the
landfill
uh thank you representative for your
question I think if I understand it
correctly the the um the health risk
part I think is addressed by the the
water quality standards that we're
required to compare to
um so the the state publishes numerical
values for both groundwater and surface
water and that's what what they hold an
applicant to for protecting that
um in order to protect human health in
the environment that comparison to the
water quality standards so that is built
into the type of Permitting work that
geologists and Engineers are involved
with regard to SB 61 it is largely
silent on aquifers as has been mentioned
do you share any concerns with it being
silent on that aspect
um thank you for your question
representative
um just to clarify are you the term
aquifer is that what you're referring to
I I'm not troubled that it's not in the
bill because it's a very specific term
um for uh that's used to denote places
where water may be extracted for potable
use and I don't think those are the
types of specifics that are being looked
at for the landfill
um the the bill rather it looks at
permeability whether it's called
colloquial and aquifer or it's measured
by its numeric value its hydraulic
conductivity that's referenced in the
bill I'd prefer the classification be
done on the number the hydraulic
any other questions thank you so much
for uh your testimony today thank you
and I now call Nancy Morrison
hmm
yes my name is Nancy Morrison and thank
you madam chair and this committee for
sitting through this very extensive
testimony it's a lot
um my testimony is two sentences
although one of them is long
uh as a New Hampshire Citizen and a
taxpayer I object to Senate Bill 61 is
written it is counterintuitive and if
the taxpayers expense that with this
bill as written Des can accept and
process a new landfill citing permit
with their admittedly understaffed and
underfunded Department during the
proposed two-year study
when that permit
may not get past the First new sighting
Senate Bill 61 would be a much better
bill for the citizens of New Hampshire
if it is amended so that Des will not
accept and process a new landfill citing
permit during the two-year study period
thank you
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
okay
good afternoon chairwoman Aaron members
of the committee and everyone
I'm Sarah Doucette from Whitefield
I have nominated myself to speak for
several thousand people
who have contacted legislators and the
governor over four years all of them
calling for responsible sighting of New
Hampshire landfills to protect the
environment their families and
communities Statewide
I commend the work of the house over
those years for being responsive and
honoring the Democratic process that
binds excuse me Mr said would you be
able to speak a little louder sorry
sorry I can ditch this too
um
so we have made progress together
with Senate Bill 61 this committee has
the opportunity in the coming days to
craft a truly effective bill that may
finally win bipartisan support write to
the governor's office in spite of his
Representatives comments to us today
as written Senate Bill 61 is only a
rough outline of what is needed for a
meaningful study what's missing is the
means to assure integrity and
accountability
you and your house colleagues can put
the essential amendment in place to turn
this bill into a worthwhile and
definitive piece of legislation for New
Hampshire Waters and Public Health
anything short of that will leave the
state with an empty process an
illegitimate outcome and yet another
failed attempt at water protection
most important your work can make
certain that New Hampshire never again
uses the existing and frightening
200-foot setback rule as a buffer
between landfills and perennial water
bodies it is appalling that that
regulation stands
given all we know about rampant pfas
contamination defaulting to the 200 foot
buffer as written now in Senate Bill 61
should the study and Rule enactment run
more than 24 months is unacceptable
study must be completed with updated and
protective regulation regulations in
effect before any permit is granted for
a new landfill facility
and in truth the whole process will
likely require a timeline that cannot be
set responsibly in advance at 24 months
or perhaps at any other specific number
of months
your work in amending will also require
attention to the search for credible
unbiased Consultants attention to the
criteria to guide their research and
attention to engineering specifications
and engineering's limitations
as well as human and environmental
health considerations
public involvement with the es both
assessing and including stakeholder
input is another requisite
it's been worrisome to hear in
legislative bodies that everyone here is
earnestly concerned about clean water
only to have votes cast against exactly
the measures that would ensure clean
water
if we want clean water we have to be
courageous
today's the time to be all in for an
amended
Senate Bill 61 that can do the job we
need I respectfully ask you committee
members to act on the convictions that
you all expressed earlier in this
session please be the diligent leaders
we need to assure that New Hampshire
never again operates with feeble
regulations for landfill citing
and please remember that I speak for
your constituents and their families
picture a few of them just for a moment
they're asking you for clean drinking
and recreational Waters
and I want to add one more thing just
before I close as a private citizen
um watching the creation of Senate Bill
I have to say that the experience the
public had in the Senate hearing was
incredibly dismissive and for this the
preparation of this bill to be
represented as an inclusive and uh
transparent process from my perspective
as someone who's paying attention on
Earthly the public really has been quite
shut out until today in that process
and you know the governor I feel the
governor is not in process with us when
I hear his Representatives say that his
decision is already made and it's
interesting to me that that
representative may not even be here
listening to anything beyond his
statement that he gave to us today
so uh I I really I've done a lot of
public comment and um
I would like to feel that it is uh
included in decision making and that we
really are in the stakeholder Circle
because it's really hard you know to get
500 votes in favor of a piece of
legislation and a handful against and it
doesn't seem to make a wit of difference
in the end so you have tremendous
Integrity for going through this with us
today I'm terrifically grateful I thank
you and I you know I look forward to
your wholehearted work on this bill I I
have a lot of confidence in your
commitment and through your earnest wish
to do something meaningful
thank you thank you any questions for Mr
representative Murray sorry thank you
madam chair this isn't that a question
for say
just clerking um you didn't indicate
support or opposition on here and if
that was intentional that's fine but I
just wanted to make sure that if you
yeah I would only support with
amendments thank you for pointing that
out I appreciate it thank you
thank you so much for your testimony I
think that um so many things of what you
said kind of ring true with some of the
questions that we had I would love you
to define the word stakeholder
um what you think the word stakeholder
means in regards with our commitment to
the public
well I mean you could guess I would stay
your constituents there are so many of
us you know we're talking about one
industry here and a relative handful of
people who I understand they have a
business interest and that's fine
but youth I don't mean just you the
legislature and the governor have heard
such
overwhelming input from stakeholders for
so long I mean
I don't like it very well that the
governor and the industry are primary
somehow on some level of stakeholdership
that none of us can achieve no matter
what we do I mean that's just it's an
odd if you want to talk about democracy
meaning something
that's not what it's about
no I don't know if I've answered your
question but I think everybody counts
not just
the big folks not just the people who
are maybe entrenched in industry or in
government
we're in a crisis no you answered it
perfectly thank you thank you
any other questions from the committee
thank you very much for your testimony I
good afternoon and welcome to
environment and agriculture
thank you very much and I do have a copy
of my remarks that'll pass out
afterwards
my name is Muriel Robinette and I
appreciate being able to address you
here I've been practicing hydrogeology
for more than 40 Years in New England
and I'm a licensed professional
geologist in New Hampshire and in Maine
Maine of which is a a neighboring state
which has landfills and landfill
regulations that happen to be quite more
specific than what ours are I am
speaking in support of Senate bill 61.
and why is that well because our 200
foot setback is currently technically
inadequate it's actually pretty scary
and we think of New Hampshire as being a
small comfortable little State and yet
we have tens of millions of acres of
land in our state and the next landfill
probably needs two or three hundred
of those Acres
so we're looking at a very site-specific
feature that we're wanting to put in
this state which is going to create
leachate and contamination for about a
hundred years that has to be managed and
addressed and taken care of
so how we cite
that next landfill is very crucial to
your grandchildren and maybe
great-grandchildren
so I think we need to do it carefully as
a geologist I love the state and we have
two main features that we we deal with
in this state one is we have beautiful
White Mountains and they came about from
Mountain building forces which rose up
the Bedrock and created fracture systems
within the rock but for those of you
who've had to drill a well for a water
supply you might have gotten a duster
you might have put in a well and maybe
gotten a quart a minute of water and yet
a quarter of a mile away or half a mile
away
someone drills a well and they get a
hundred gallons a minute or 200 gallons
a minute if you're a municipality and
have used some some good science in
finding those fracture systems
so we have great variability in this
state
the other feature that we have a lot of
to thank for are the glaciers that came
through about 15 million years ago
because the glaciers scraped our
mountains and they left behind a very
clay-rich Stony substance called till
and if you've ever tried to grow a
garden in it good luck because it
doesn't move water very easily for you
but the glaciers also left us excellent
sand and gravel deposits where it was
flowing all the melting back
so that too is site specific so when we
cite a landfill maybe we ought to look
for some of these features which can
pass groundwater very very rapidly sand
and gravel it can pass tens of feet a
day of groundwater which means if
contaminants get gets in it it can move
tens of feeds a day
with a contamination so how can possibly
a 200 foot setback be adequate for a
site that would have that kind of a
deposit the same concept for fractured
Rock if you have high fractures it can
pass ground water quite rapidly too so
all we're looking for and needing to
have to be protective in this state is
site-specific citing criteria now
certainly we have a lot of site specific
criteria that is evaluated when a permit
is applied and we have very competent
hydrogeologists in the state in the Des
and in the private sector there some of
them are sitting here now and I highly
respect their capabilities
what we want to see is them to apply
that site-specific information
to the inevitable situation of leachate
transport
so the upshot of it all is that this
Senate Bill 61 says let's study it
that's a that's a admirable concept and
admirable from the standpoint of how
much can you do for a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
it's going to be a desktop study it's
going to be a statistical analysis it
will be a study that looks at some of
the other states that and how they do
setbacks which is all good and valuable
and useful
to the GES and how they change their
setback criteria for landfills so we
need to give them the time to do that
job we need to allow the science to be
applied in the study and that advice
given to Des and they'll very
competently evaluate it with respect to
sighting of landfills
and I would just implore you to not
allow this work this good work which
will happen to be circumvented by the
fact that it might miss its deadline by
a month or two or three
landfills create contamination for 100
years and where we put the next one is
really important particularly when we
know about our pfas concentrations in
the leachate we don't want that getting
into our water supplies
so let's give them the time and let's
not have a sunset clause on that 200
any questions
150 000
uh in the appropriation were you saying
that you believed that was adequate or
inadequate I just wanted to clarify for
the record
well I think 150 000 is adequate for a
desktop study and I think that is is
makes sense because for anything
additional in other words to expect a
consultant to go out and do independent
permeability testing or any kind of
field analysis is is going to be biased
by how much and where they can do it so
I'm not criticizing it I'm just pointing
that out as the fact that it's going to
be a desktop study but it will develop
excellent information I believe that
will help guide Des
thank you representative
excuse me representative Howard thank
you madam chair
um to piggyback on to representative
Murray's question do you think that what
is basically the equivalent of a
literary survey would be sufficient to
inform the rules going forward
I do think it is because number for two
reasons one is that its goal
is to come up with a site-specific
setback criteria that's a number one
critical
and then number two the fact is that it
also will compare what New Hampshire
currently has to other rules nearby in
our states and and I do point to Maine's
landfill Solid Waste rules I I think
they're they're pretty doggone good and
they're much more protective than New
Hampshire's
representative dutzy thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
uh did you testify on HB 1540 uh 1454
any other questions
representative coulon
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um so what it sounds like you're saying
to me is that you think the language and
this bill allows for a discovery of the
site specific
I do attributes and not every site is
probably a little bit different I do
because I think that the consultant will
develop the data to show the diversity
of the site-specific information
hydrogeologically that would go into
determining what sort of safe setback
should be and I personally think a time
of travel makes a lot of sense it's it's
technically viable and understood and
it's used in other places
and so maybe they'll come back and say
you know five years six years 10 years
two years I don't know but I would
assume that they will then be comparing
whatever it is they think they're coming
up with with what other states are doing
also thank you
representative Bixby yeah I'd like to
dig into the a little bit deeper into
the term site-specific criteria it kind
of rolls off the tongue easily but uh I
think it might be easy to miss that so
when you're saying site specific that is
just you know one site not yet not
another site but when you get to the
word criteria isn't that where the
generalization comes in that there are
uh there are General patterns that you
can use to look at every different site
and those and and that's where you get
consistency
I if I understand your question
correctly
um there are
every site is different
and when one is evaluating the specifics
of a site it's not one data point it's
many data points of the various material
you're looking at or it's a site with
respect to it's set back to other
features whether it's airports or
schools or surface water
so it you collect you develop and you
collect and evaluate data specifically
for the site in question
but I so I guess so you get you have all
that specific site data but there has to
be some way to compare one site to
another and that's where the idea of the
criteria come in that you you need to
you need to have some basis of
comparison as well as the individual
data points well the Des does require
when one says this is where I would like
to build my my landfill site that you
evaluate other sites to and compare them
so there is that comparison that's done
in the permitting process
thank you
representative germano uh thank you very
much Madam chair and thank you for for
uh taking my question when we had the
testimony on on HP 56 we heard from a
number of folks who have a lot of you
know relevant background in Hydro
geology one of the things that I found
confusing that we talked a bit about was
that we heard like six different things
from six different experts right so
when we're talking about a consultant
one consultant who comes back after an
RFP and provides this uh you know
recommendations with regard to a set of
criteria
uh how were we with one consultant in
that case to be assured that you know if
we hired five other Consultants we
wouldn't have five other sets of
criteria that were recommended as you
said we've heard testimony from lots of
folks with lots of different views on on
on the distance of setback travel time
Etc so I guess it comes down to you know
what what makes us think that if we
hired six Consultants we wouldn't have
six separate sets of recommendations
I think you probably would have six
separate recommendations but they all
may be centering around the same thing
which is that maybe it is travel time or
maybe it is some other criteria that
they all agree on
um I I think the the greatest
discrepancy I've heard so far with um
among the hydrogeologists is how much do
you rely upon the engineered safeguards
and systems that landfills are required
to design into their their facilities
their operations Etc and if if one wants
to accept that they're Fail-Safe and
they will be for a hundred years then
then you know maybe a hydrogeologist
would come back and say you know maybe
the setback is good at 300 feet or
something but if if one does accept that
some contamination will happen and where
does it go and how fast does it go and
so then what sort of of setback then is
protective and I would suspect that that
Des will will think about this pretty
hard and give some guidance to the
Consultants that they're that whatever
they come back with needs to be quote in
in the norm there are a lot of states
that are dealing with landfills and
dealing with contamination and migration
and whatever so how are they looking at
it versus
um what would happen assuming the
inevitable will happen over 100 years
there will be releases so where does it
go how fast does it go what can we do to
put in our citing rules that is that
gives us a shot at being protective
follow up thank you and and so then when
in the end doesn't it come down to If
you're looking at several sets of
recommendations and doesn't it in the
end come down to a value determination
in particular by a legislative body in
terms of how
long we think we need to have to make
sure that we don't have contamination
this goes to Senator bixby's or
representative now I'm doing it
representative bixby's uh point about
Criterion right that that you have all
of that data how do you determine
how you're going to implement that
recommendation isn't it in the end
ultimately a value statement by a
representative body that determines
which set of recommendations you're
going to apply if you're going to be
more airing on the side of caution or
less
possibilities because
you know how protective of all of the
stakeholders do you want to be it costs
a lot of money to deal with failures and
and we don't cavalierly want to go and
and head in that direction so that we're
always spending money on failures and
and but you also don't want to say well
I guess we won't have any more landfills
ever for the next thousand years because
that's probably not going to actually
work either so you have a very
interesting job in balancing
your requirements yeah I do and when the
failure is pfas contamination to me it's
clear which side we should lean toward
but thank you very much for your your
answer representative Bixby yeah so um
I'm uh your comments on uh how different
hydrogeologists and Consultants might
come up with slightly different answers
but you can if you look at all of them
together then you might get some better
ideas uh makes me think about uh in
section five uh
uh part one
um the Department of Environmental
Services shall contract with one or more
qualified consulting firms for
individuals to perform an assessment do
you think it might make sense to require
it's going to if you did something like
that it's going to take longer it's
going to draw out the process it's going
to create
um
compromising within the department with
the two Consultants whatever you
frankly I think you can do just fine
with one okay thank you just choosing
choosing a good one that that doesn't
have a dog in the fight all right thank
you very much
appreciate your uh your testimony
and
okay thank you
um I'll call now Kirsten Coke
is it Coke or Koch
touch I'm sorry
Kirsten Koch
foreign
Madam chair Representatives um it's been
a long day I know so I will be very
brief my name is Kirsten Koch I'm
director of public policy for the
business and industry Association
Statewide Chamber of Commerce also known
as Bia and I come before you today to
register Bia support for Senate bill 61.
we support this bill as a vehicle for
modernizing landfill permitting because
we believe it requires scientific
studies to be done and subsequently
update rules and regulations based on
the scientific data from those studies
it's long been a policy priority for the
business and industry Association to
support efforts to create science-based
rules or legislation and we think this
does exactly that we believe this bill
is the best way to go for updating
landfill permitting because we see it as
fair and scientifically accurate in the
senate senate Bill 61 received a support
from a broad variety of folks from
environmental experts industry leaders
and environmental activists
as Senator Waters explained earlier
there's clearly a bipartisan desire to
create a solution here and we hope to
see that come forward we strongly
support Senate Bill 61 and we believe
this bill provides a fair solution
accurately updating landfill permitting
in conclusion we asked the committee to
please pass Senate Bill 61. thank you
for your consideration I'd be happy to
try to answer any questions
Miss coach do you have a written
testimony at all to share with us I can
provide it okay thank you that's
appreciated
representative Bixby uh does the Bia
have a position
um in terms of uh whether the
um if the 24 month deadline is not met
whether it should revert to Old rules
thank you for the question
um
we came prepared just to discuss the
bill as is and not amendments but
ultimately you know we support this bill
because we want to see these changes
come forward within the 24 months we see
that provision as another additional
Safeguard ultimately it's a policy
decision for the committee to bake
thank you
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon thank you
good afternoon
foreign
sorry about that good afternoon I'm
Nikki delude Roy I am a professional
geologist licensed in the state of New
Hampshire I am also vice president of a
company named verdantis we are an
environmental and engineering firm with
an office here in Manchester New
Hampshire but we have offices in about
26 States currently and practice
environmental and Engineering across all
of those States
I appreciate you all hearing my
testimony as you all probably know I've
reviewed and commented on bills on the
same topic in this and in previous
legislative sessions and so I am here
today in support of SB 61
because I believe that this proposed
Bill really ultimately goes back to the
expertise that is at DES with regards to
making the appropriate sets of rules for
that reflect the geology and the setting
and the stakeholders in the state
I'll um I'll be brief today because I
think Muriel and others who have
testified earlier this afternoon have
spoken to all of the complexities around
the issue of citing landfills in the
state
for example there were a number of
questions regarding the definition of an
aquifer
it really just speaks to how complex the
geology is here and how important it is
that the legislature basically Direct
Des to go into the rulemaking process
and think be thoughtful about the the
update to the solid waste regulations
and specifically to the sighting regs
I'd also like to emphasize that by
through SB 61 and through the
investigation or the study that has been
referenced and discussed previously this
afternoon There's an opportunity for the
best science across the country to be
evaluated brought forward
recommended to Des put into context with
the geology here in the state and for
ultimately for Des to incorporate that
um
so I will just end I guess my testimony
here today just to say how supportive I
am of sb61 because ultimately it brings
into the the consideration of practice
the state of practice across the country
as well as the site-specific geology in
the state and then It ultimately relies
on the experts at DES to go through the
rulemaking process that they have
in-house so thank you for consideration
my comments
thank you any questions for
representative Howard
um is it is oh thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question
um is verdantis also uh um under
contract with the state we are not
okay
any other questions
seeing none
that was my last pink card
so if anyone else would like to make
comments or testimony
please come up to the microphone fill
out a pink card
you know okay
um
the online portal
has 47 people in support of this bill 81
opposed and five neutral
in our blue sheet has four people in
favor and one person opposed to SB 61.
and uh
I guess we are at the end of our our uh
hearing for this today
I want to thank everybody for their
patience and their fortitude for making
it this far
especially our committee members for
sitting so patiently and answering I
mean uh asking some very very good
questions along the way
so I am going to close this hearing on
thank you
um so my intention here is now that
we've heard all the bills that we've
heard today
um
next week we are scheduled on Tuesday to
have a tour of unh
uction okay
okay
and
that's going to include the um
uh agricultural uh research station
yeah so
um some of the things that we're going
to be seeing
um are so uh we're going to hear from uh
the director of the Agricultural
research station
um who if uh also was the one who gave
us the greenhouse tour last month uh and
uh that's Anton Beckerman and we're
going to hear from uh the
um Cooperative Extension we're going to
see the research Farms out at Woodman
Farm we're going to see the organic
Dairy we're going to hear from a
researcher who is working on water
quality with uh um with particular
attention to contaminants like pfas uh
and
um I think we might have a couple there
might be a couple there there's a very
full day that's going to be presented to
us and we're going to get a lot of
interesting information
I will be sending out to the committee
um I think we've already gotten it but
I'll resend it the agenda for that you
had a proposed agenda yeah there was a
there was a um there was a draft agenda
which will probably be pretty close to
the whole thing and so if we I can touch
base with Campbell Valley and uh see if
we can get the uh a final version the
final final version of the agenda and
then we'll share it with everybody and
give dress code dress code
um um wear shoes you don't mind getting
muddy
okay so we have uh next week we've got
this tour
the 9th May 9th my plan is to
exec most of the bills that we heard
today and we may have a work session
on maybe SB 61 or any of the other ones
that may need it
um
and if we have any kind of amendments
we'll discuss it then and then we'll
have to figure out whether later in the
day not it wouldn't be later in the day
because we would have some sort of
amendments unless we would discuss the
Amendments that morning and then execut
in the afternoon I think what would make
sense is that we should plan on having a
work session in the morning where we
could discuss any amendments and uh we
can also make sure that those amendments
go out to people in advance so they have
a good chance chance to think about them
uh and uh if there are not if if we can
uh settle if we agree on the amendments
in that work session then we can it
should be straightforward to exec in the
afternoon
uh and I think we can I would guess that
with
the exception of possibly one bill we'd
be able to exec everything yeah
yeah so that's kind of the plan
and um
I don't know if anybody else has any
questions about anything you've heard
today or
but we
sure
will these the bills that we've seen to
date are the the last of our bills for
this session yes okay thank you when
we're done with these we're done
until the fall when we'll go over the
bills that we've retained
so
okay
all right with that I'm gonna call it a
day and thank you all for sticking in
yeah
with
our caucus
the whole committee
yeah sure
um members of the committee please stay
and I'm going to ask
um well I don't know that we can do that
if we have a discussion of yeah any kind
of discussion of any of the bills is a
right
foreign